the big news over the weekend the bridge
to Crimea from Russia was bombed now the
mainstream media they're saying we don't
know who did it some reports are that
obviously it was Ukrainian military of
some sort why wouldn't it be why would
it be anybody else unless you want to
argue there's a third party trying to
instigate War it makes perfect sense
that Ukraine is going to try and cut off
Russia from Crimea and try and take
Crimea back in response to this Vladimir
Putin launched 84 missiles peppering in
the entire country about 40 of them at
least the reporting I saw were
intercepted several of them landed the
most worrisome of course was the German
Embassy being hit by the by the Russian
strike so obviously now there's concerns
over escalation Germany is going to be
sending in some kind of missile defense
Joe Biden has promised some kind of
missile defense so
I don't know World War III Donald Trump
is warning about it again saying that we
need to stop this now we need to
negotiate he's offered to help in the
past that we may be entering World War
III and we have no time to waste now
back on the domestic front we have big
news that I have to address and that's
PayPal
because you may have seen the news that
PayPal launched this uh policy where if
you engage in hate speech or
misinformation they can find you charge
your account two thousand five hundred
dollars they quickly backtracked after
Elon Musk and some other PayPal a former
president of PayPal called them out and
said everyone should just shut their
accounts down I think PayPal got hurt by
this because we can see on our end the
people who still use PayPal even though
we've got gotten off the website we've
lost a decent amount of users and we can
we're getting emails from people saying
that's it the final straw they're
switching over
we're gonna talk about that story PayPal
is backtrack saying it was an error
there are some documents archived
suggesting it wasn't and that they're
just panicking it's backfiring but I
will say this before we get started head
over to timcast.com click the join us
button and then click become a member
choose whatever number you want to click
and you will see that we have parallel
economy parallel economy was co-founded
by Dan bongino we got PayPal off the
website a long time ago we did this
because we knew they were censoring
people and they were going to escalate
their ESG social credit score BS I'm
glad we did and I'm glad as many of you
as possible moved over now what we
didn't do is we didn't discontinue
PayPal for those that are Legacy members
of the website going back almost a year
now and are on members with PayPal your
memberships are fine but many of you I
noticed have been canceling we hope that
you come back and sign up using parallel
economy and for those that still use
PayPal you can switch over it's not
super easy you may have to actually just
cancel your account and re-sign up and
and that's if you used a guest account
with PayPal I'm not entirely sure and in
all honestly my apologies in that it's a
fairly rudimentary website with limited
Tech because we we don't have you know
200 million subscribers like like uh
Netflix or anything like that but if you
haven't already head over to timcast.com
and become a member utilize parallel
economy for two reasons One support us
support our journalists support our work
support our show and to support parallel
economy this is Dan bongino co-founded
this company
if we can get more and more users onto
parallel economy help them expand grow
and become a bigger portion of the
market share then we can actually push
back against these ESG garbage
corporations so that's one way to do it
now
let's talk about what's going on joining
us today to discuss World War III Russia
nuclear weapons is actually somebody who
has a PHD in Battlefield nuclear warfare
I think is that it drew Miller Dr Drew
Miller
yes Tim my uh PhD from Harvard was on
underground nuclear defense shelters and
field fortifications for NATO troops so
it's the topic today but I wrote it
decades ago and even then it was
politically Politically Incorrect to
talk about the limited use of nuclear
weapons and we saw this again on
Thursday when President Biden said that
you know you can quote him here I don't
think there's any such thing as ability
to easily use the tactical nuclear
weapon and not end up with Armageddon
and that's what the Democratic party has
been saying for decades but it's just
not true if Russia were to use a nuclear
weapon on the battlefield against
Ukrainian troops we would be crazy as
the United States to escalate that to a
strategic nuclear exchange with Russia
that I was reading the same thing there
was that quote that I mentioned where
the the guy said you'd be have to be a
Madman to sacrifice Boston for posanan
so we'll talk about that especially with
the news pertaining to Russia but you're
also the CE CEO of fortitude Ranch full
disclosure I have a I have a stake in
the in in fortitude Ranch but this is uh
what would you call call it is is it
preparedness afforded Ranch is a
recreational and survival community so
in Good Times our members can come out
and use our shooting range and hike and
enjoy the rural locations we're in we're
in five states now but in bad times we
turn into survival Community our members
come out to stay alive and get out of
cities and suburbs where if the gridas
go down I mean if Russia does an EMP
attack on us our grid is toast it'll be
gone for over a year and there's no
Municipal Water Systems you will die in
cities and suburbs so our members will
come to our rural locations where we're
equipped to you know survive long term
with food and water but also all our
members have weapons as well as our
staff so we can defend ourselves against
Marauders and survive anything this is
going to be really interesting I'm
excited for this conversation about
Marauders in survival so thanks for
coming we also got lucrid Caskey hanging
out someone said shooting range I'm all
in I'm very happy for this conversation
this is going to be a very important one
my name is we are change.org and today
I'm wearing a t-shirt which represents
how war is a racket showing of course
the king and queens having dinner while
of course the ponds kill each other off
and that to me is the true reality of
war no one wins them except the special
interest if you like the shirt you could
get it on the best politicalshirts.com
because you do I am here thank you again
so much for having me and uh Hey guys
Ian crossing here I had a couple of
Corrections from last week at one point
I said that Alexander the Great and his
band uh invaded and conquered Ursa Minor
it was in outer space not right it was
actually not the Little Dipper uh no no
they conquered Asia Minor which is
turkey Anatolia things like that and
also I mentioned last week Luke and I
were talking a little bit about tactical
nuclear weapons I said that depleted
uranium rounds are a type of tactical
nuclear weapon because they have minor
amounts of radiation but Drew you were
saying it's no they're not classified as
nuclear weapons no they're strictly
Conventional Weapons got it I just want
to say Ian if we made a Sci-Fi cartoon
about the future about a guy named
Alexander who gets a spaceship and goes
and conquers Ursa Minor I'll be pretty
epic space epic yeah yeah there you go
and then technically you weren't wrong
that's right okay let's write on this
that's right and uh many of you may
already know if you tuned in on Friday
that Lydia is no longer with the program
she has moved on she's going to be doing
uh her own thing and we'll we'll shout
her out when uh when she's ready for
that but uh pushing all the buttons
today is surge
hey guys nice to meet you my name is
Serge aka the new Lydia pleasure to be
here except the guy yeah except I am a
guy Linda Jr yes nice hair too and the
junior thanks I appreciate it guys all
right let's jump into this first story
we've got from the Jerusalem Post
Russian strikes hit hits German
diplomatic office in Kiev report the
German Embassy in Kiev was hit by
Russian airstrikes on Monday German
media Outlet build reported however the
building has not been in use since the
war broke out the foreign Ministry said
russian-born journalist and political
scientist Sergey you some Lemmy probably
pronouncing that wrong now based in
Berlin tweeted about the attack asking
for Chancellor Olaf Schultz and other
German officials to issue a response to
the airstrike so okay they've not been
using it but this is still this is if
this is the German Embassy this is
German territory right
so what does this mean does this mean
that Germany is now going to use this as
some kind of Casa's belly declare war or
is it is it meaningless well
specifically it was their Visa office
and it looked like a lot of these
strikes weren't for their intended
targets there's one inside of a
playground when Russia of course was
making a speech saying that this was
specific strategic attacks against the
infrastructure of Ukraine uh the the
German Embassy isn't really
infrastructure of Ukraine but there's a
lot of other things happening behind the
scenes I don't think Germany is going to
be doing anything with this I I think
Germany right now also is having a major
bullet shortage I I think that also is
something we should be keeping a close
eye on but there's a lot of other things
happening with Belarus right now with
Poland telling their citizens to leave
Belarus right now Poland is also
checking their uh bunkers right now to
make to make sure that they're up and
running and that they're running
properly so a lot of other things are
happening and this is just episode one
according to the former Ukrainian
president Medvedev of many episodes to
come when it comes to these larger
strikes that Russia is going to be
launching on Ukraine I will mention this
from the reporting they're trying to
make it seem like you know so Germany
condemns you know Russia's actions in
Ukraine then all of a sudden there's an
airstrike some one one of the strikes
happen at a German Embassy and now
Germany is set to deliver air defense
system uh to Ukraine within days
according to the defense Ministry so uh
Reuters reporting Germany will deliver
the first of four Iris tslm air defense
systems Ukraine within days
and well there you go that's it
I don't I think what we've seen from
NATO for the most part has just been
acting like they're not involved but
basically supplying the overwhelming
majority of weapons strategy
intelligence everything and then you
even have volunteers now we do know last
week this was reported by The Intercept
that U.S Special uh operations are
underway in Ukraine so at what point is
this just world war three
well there's some big concerns that the
escalation will continue and and it's
it's kind of odd but the worse it gets
for Putin uh the worse it really gets
for for U.S security because he is a
he's losing the war clearly doing poorly
prospects aren't good for him so he's a
desperate uh dictator and he doesn't
want to get killed off knocked out of
power so he's got to change the
situation and to do that he's got to do
one of a couple things he could use
nuclear weapons in the Ukraine I don't
think it would escalate I think it would
destroy a lot of Ukrainian forces but
there is a risk that you know it could
go to not just using them on the
battlefield but using them near the
border where the supplies are coming in
from Poland and Germany and U.S
equipment coming in that gets close to
New to Nato territory in risks that we
might get involved but more likely and I
think more threatening for the United
States uh is Putin If he if he doesn't
he gets into any nuclear exchange with
the US he loses from that we would
severely hurt him we'd of course be
massively damaged but it would hurt
Russia tremendously so I think he's more
likely to do something like release a
virus clandestinely in the United States
and West Europe something that's not
like covid but something like human
human transmissible avian flu 60 lethal
highly transmissible and at that point
60 avian flu if a human gets avian flu
it's not directly transmissible now but
they have your tax dollars were used and
gain of function research to develop
human to human transmissible mammal to
mammal transmissible versions of avian
flu which is 60 lethal to humans and if
he releases that virus and the way to do
that was published in open source
literature a decade ago and so if Russia
releases a human human transmissible
form of avian flu it'll spread like mad
and at that point who cares about
Ukraine we're trying to stay alive over
here it would be an absolute collapse
situation in the United States already
who cares about Ukraine we're trying to
survive over here I mean the economies
in in shambles we've got Biden they're
sending tons of money off to Ukraine
most Americans can't even point to it on
a map and we're wondering why it is we
are actively involved in a border
dispute with Russia and Ukraine yeah I
kind of have a little different
perspective than than you drew just a
little bit because I I think we're in
the stage where not all options have
been kind of used here I think this
conflict is going to be going back and
forth now with the winter coming to
Ukraine a lot of the forces are going to
be stalled and I think it's going to be
like that for a very long time I think
that the concept of of uh Kissinger
limited Perpetual war is something that
we truly face the reality of and I see
Putin having a lot more options at the
table before going nuclear before even
going bio weapon uh before even going
you know full crazy Mad Men as people
describe them in the media uh before
doing that I I think there's other
Conventional Weapons of war that he
could release there's other attacks he
could do on the Ukrainian infrastructure
and I think he's is going to be using
those methods first even though the
threat of nuclear war is serious but I
think it's it's less probable than a
more aggravated bigger escalation on the
ground from my perspective I don't think
Putin's yet begun to fight I think we've
what we've seen it's like ground forces
in the East now with these missile
strikes over over Ukraine
I think if Putin wanted to he could
unleash substantially more destruction
on the country if he really felt he had
yeah like what we did in Afghanistan and
Iraq was nowhere near even an inkling of
the capability we had of Destruction
because we didn't want to destroy it we
wanted to conquer it and he doesn't want
to destroy Ukraine he wants to conquer
it or at least eastern Ukraine yeah well
General Petraeus was on recently saying
that you know he he thinks that Russia
is in an absolute no-win situation there
and it's getting worse for them and I
tend to agree with that assessment that
Russia has clearly lost this war in a
conventional fight then mobilizing isn't
going to do anything near term and their
their troops just are not motivated for
understandable reasons they're not
defending Russian Homeland they're
invading another country and so the
situation is bad for people and it's
also horrible for him on the home front
bad things are going on there so I think
he could now already be in a desperate
situation but he's not going to be
desperate he's a smart ruthless evil man
so he's not going to do something
desperate like launch a nuclear strike
on in the United States that would be
incredibly stupid he is not stupid he's
brilliantly ruthless evil so I think
he's far more likely to do is release a
clandestine bio attack on the United
States that's the smartest what's the
over under for small tackle small
tactical nuclear weapon what's the
betting odds for in your opinion for
this bio weapon what do you think is
most likely by percentage uh I think if
he's the smartest most effective thing
he could do would be to get a
distraction that takes Ukraine off the
map and gets our support both the U.S
and the Western European support
eliminated quickly and you know what he
did over the weekend well he's got more
now more Western Arms coming into the
Ukraine that doesn't really help him
doesn't change the bad military
situation for him he needs to knock us
out of providing support to Ukraine and
our politicians aren't going to back
down that would look bad it's too much
comparisons to Chamberlain in World War
II so he's got to do something different
and drastic and the way to do it is a
clan destined again not a not an overt
but a clandestine release of a bio
weapon and they've absolutely got all
kinds of viruses smallpox you name it
they've got it but so they release it
over here and you know we are not going
to be sending arms to Ukraine certainly
I do more military forces into NATO if
we're dealing with the pandemic that's
killing off our population and worse
it's unleashing loss of Law and Order as
people are trying to survive and you've
got massive marauding going on across
the United States and millions dying
from that how do you if Putin were to
release a virus what's to stop Russia
from getting hit by it eventually it
would spread but it slid a lot more
slowly if they release it over here not
a whole lot of Air flight going into
Russia right now from the United States
or Western Europe they're already
effectively isolated and the other
person who could do this is the North
Korean dictator he's another person you
know he's at the bottom rank of
effective good places you know power
powerful Nations if there's a pandemic
worldwide great place to be would be
North Korea you don't have you don't
have international travel you you know
you got you know everyone else now gets
destroyed we could lose most of our
population Western Europe most of that
everyone else comes down in power and
Prestige and North Korea Now isn't so
much at the bottom uh they're a country
that survived the Miss I'd rather be in
North Korea than South Korea when
there's an international pandemic of
Evian flu spreading but what people
sometimes don't take into account is
clean water the ability to wash yourself
with soap and clean water and how that
can help you overcome a disease so like
people in North Korea that are are
literally sometimes eating other people
because they're starving might be end up
being much sicker from a disease even if
it's there's less of a load in the
environment because they don't have
access to the same kind of treatments
that we do correct but if that virus
kills off most of South Korea and North
Korea can evade it they can now take
South Korea after the viruses died out
when the people are dead
is there anything you're seeing from an
intelligence report that suggests that
there's a probability that this is going
to happen and again what's the
probability from 0 to 100 that you think
this is going to happen well I'm a
Former Intelligence officer so nothing I
say tonight will be a release of
classified information on terms of
probability I mean Nasim Talib wrote the
most important valuable book I've ever
read in my life the Black Swan the
influence of the highly improbable and
he trains you not to talk in
probabilities how can I talk about the
probability of something that's never
happened before there's no statistical
evidence for me to use so it's you know
it's expert guesstimation is the honest
term for it but you know you can reason
from people and from past situations and
Putin former KGB agent and absolutely
ruthless man you know he knows about the
power of bioweapons they've had him in
the Soviet Union they're biological
weapons program the Soviet Union had
like 60 to 80 000 people working in it
they developed all kinds of agents and
and we the United States continue to do
as I said gain a function research where
we demonstrate it and then published the
results on how to create a mammal to
mammal contagious we were using ferrets
version of avian flu 60 lethality and we
published it so everyone all over the
world if they want to know how to do it
they've learned it yeah so he's got the
ability to do this and it's a smart
thing for him to do and then if you
discipline desperately
but we also got reports that Putin was
allegedly terrified of kovid and that he
kind of insulated himself away from
other people the way Russia kind of
handled covid I think would also have an
impact on that because they didn't
really do that good of a job they did
have very strict lockdowns and mandates
they didn't really work just like
anywhere else do you think do you see
that kind of playing into this larger
decision and we don't have to get into
you know obvious intelligence reports
and classified information but do you
think it's more likely than a small
tactical nuclear weapon uh I think a
limited use of Battlefield of nuclear
weapons is a highly likely thing and I
think release of virus is highly likely
both on there be there's no way for me
to estimate the probability I'm not even
sure Putin would know at this point
unless he's already made the decision
and issued the order what would
Battlefield nuclear weapons look like
like what's an example of one and how
would it play out uh sure well
Battlefield nuclear weapon I
distinguished between Battlefield use
theater use which is more like a longer
range strike and to for example the
Eastern uh parts of the Ukraine near the
border of Poland for example but
Battlefield use is limited to attacking
other combat troops it's probably going
to be an air burst not a ground
detonation they don't want the Fallout
coming into the Russian territory but
you can do a low yield it could be less
than a kiloton you know for example
Hiroshima is you know about 15 kiloton
it could be a one kiloton it could be
less than a kiloton we gave up we
unilaterally
dismantled and destroyed our tactical
Battlefield nuclear weapons back in 1991
the first George Bush president they got
nothing in return Russia kept theirs
China's kept and expanded and modernized
there they still had them so they could
absolutely annihilate Ukrainian Ground
Forces
why isn't he why is Putin not yet using
low-yield nukes to just clear the field
and take the land uh because he hasn't
been in a desperate enough situation
thus far once you do that you know it's
it's
it is an escalation there is a risk that
you know uh potentially you know we'll
I'll give you one example once this
happens and he gets away with it I think
he would get away with it the U.S is not
going to respond with the nuclear attack
on Russia if they do a nuclear
detonation in Ukraine that would be
insane for President Biden to do he
would not do that so if they do that and
he gets away with them now what's going
to happen to nuclear non-proliferation
because we've told all our NATO members
and Japan and so many countries we will
protect you with our nuclear umbrella
and it's not believable it's never been
credible and this will prove that it's
not credible that we will not use
nuclear weapons most likely even to
defend our allies in Ukraine you know
thus far is not a NATO member not an
ally we have to defend I've been saying
uh basically this for a while and I've
had other people argue people argue with
me that I said mutually assured
destruction is just that's not true this
idea that I suppose the idea is if if
Russia decides to Nuke DC then the U.S
will will fire back in Moscow or
something like that but what I was
saying is that this idea that the use of
nuclear weapons in general results in
everyone just firing nukes and blowing
everybody up in fact there's one really
obvious reason why NATO will not nuke
back in the war the wars in Ukraine
Russia has invaded the Eastern region
Putin can fire nukes into Ukraine
anywhere he wants and causes much damage
as he wants because he's trying to take
it NATO does not want to destroy Ukraine
they're trying to push Russia out so
theoretically if Russia moves too far
into Ukraine say in the Eastern region
then maybe they'll use nukes there but
they'd be effectively losing by doing it
cutting off their nose to spite their
face well a couple things I worry about
here is that we're in a desperate
situation I I think the Russians in some
instances are desperate I think the
ukrainians are also desperate here and
they know that that they're facing a lot
of very tough odds here they have a lot
of support but at the end of the day
Russia still has a lot more manpower
Russia still has a lot more bullets even
though there's a lot of countries
selling them bullets Germany has a
bullet shortage I think this is more
significant than we're uh that that of
course is not being talked about here I
I think in this desperation we shouldn't
rule out the possibility of someone
staging an attack or staging an incident
that would escalate this situation
possibly get other countries involved
here right now we have Belarus do a
joint military task force with Russia
they're mobilizing on the Ukrainian
border they've been mobilizing for a
couple months now but I think we're in a
situation where the the history of the
previous world wars is rhyming and and
what happened then was other countries
got involved and I I think there's a big
possibility that Ukraine in their
desperation or Russia in their
desperation could stage an event that
could be the galvanizing event that
could launch a bigger conflict here that
would move Beyond this proxy war between
Russia and the United States do you
think that's a possibility yeah it's
absolutely true that that could happen
but you know people like to make
comparisons back in history as you
mentioned back to World War II and you
know Hitler didn't have nuclear weapons
nor did they have biological weapons or
the ability to release them in the
United States Putin does so you got a
corner dog a guy who's desperate wants
to retain power and we should not be
provoking him I'm glad to support
Ukraine if we can but we should not be
pushing Russia and Putin in the
desperate man in no situation where he
feels like the only way I'm going to
stay alive and stay in power is to knock
the U.S and Western European support out
of Ukraine and I do that either with
escalating with nuclear weapons which is
really a risky for me because they could
eventually retaliate with nuclear
weapons against me or I could be smart
about it and just release a biological
agent that starts a horrible pandemic in
the U.S and Western I think you do the
latter now now I just want to talk about
this biological agent because you know
you bring it up a couple times in the
1957 to 1958 avian flu pandemic that
killed two million people and they say
it's not as effective as a bio weapon
because the host usually dies and
transmission is less likely when we have
such a very strong virus do you have any
counter evidence or is there a new type
of thing that you know about from your
work and intelligence that that says
that this is going to be different in
the 1957-1958 avian flute sure that's a
very low lethality of ours I mean it's
worse than avian flu but you're talking
about like one percent lethality look at
that of the the so-called misnamed
Spanish Flu back at the end of World War
One 1919 1920 time frame that was like a
1.5 percent lethality rate avian flu is
way less not I'm sorry even flusueva I'm
sorry covid-19 is like way you know it's
.001 lethality very very low but avian
flu as I said a 60 lethal now when you
modify it you may get a different
lethality rate it may be a lot lower it
may be higher I don't know you're
changing the virus yeah but the question
I have is if people are getting it and
dying right away the virus won't spread
as fast correct uh viruses generally
it's better for them not to be too
highly lethal you kill off all your
hosts but it's well it's really simple I
mean gain of function research you get
you get a virus you get something as
lethal as an avian flu but you engineer
it to have a two-week delay in ons and
symptoms that's the worst that's the
third thing I mean I've been talking
about transmissibility and lethality but
Tim you just brought up the third really
bad thing if it's got a latency period
where I'm contagious this I'm spreading
the virus but I don't have any symptoms
yet then you're really really screwed
over we were talking about this last
week that you know look nuclear weapons
the Advent of which was over 80 years
ago you get this report published in
1938 I can't remember who who shot it
out is that will mentioned that 1938 on
the the scientific paper on fission and
then all of a sudden everybody gets the
idea like you could make a bomb with
that and then finally we did and what
was uh what was the um there was a fat
man was it like a 15 kiloton bomb or
something like that that's the name of
one of those was fat man they're both
about 15 20 kilotons
15 to 20 kilotons nothing compared to
the nukes that they currently have today
especially with mervs when they have
multiple Warheads
but bringing that up I mean this is old
technology you'd have to imagine they've
developed different and new capabilities
in Modern Warfare that we don't know
about and we won't know about until they
do I think Fair Point biological weapon
seems to be the route to take yeah who
knows what Peter dazek and the CIA are
doing with Echo Health Alliance with Dr
Falcon's funding still as they got
funded again but but I think there's
also another important aspect you know
viruses usually don't spread well
without any kind of symptoms sneeze and
coughing is how viruses usually spread
if they develop something new I don't
know but uh this would be end of the
world you you launch a bio weapon it's
going to affect everyone through the
food supply covet was found in ice cream
and it can live in animal fat you got to
watch out for food just from my
assessment my research I do think
smaller escalations more attacks on on
the infrastructure in Ukraine and I
think you know a bigger all-out war and
and potential false flags are more of a
possibility than buy weapons from my
perspective in my opinion yeah yeah but
hold on we're not like I I don't know if
this is what you're saying but my view
is not that Putin right now is just like
a flu no he goes with artillery goes
nuclear artillery he goes tactical nukes
in the event of total desperation when
with U.S involvement getting too heavy
and his conventional method's not
working and his escalation not working I
think I would agree that someone maybe
it's Putin maybe it's not someone's
going to try and and knock out the US
economy either by uh you know well I
would assume a clever way to hit the
United States clandestine as you
mentioned is a bio weapon yes and
remember back in March um the Russians
were putting out propaganda saying hey
the U.S has these biological weapons
programs in the Ukraine and why in the
world were they doing it it made no
sense but they were talking about gain
of function research and allege that we
were doing bioweapons work with the
ukrainians this was going on in March of
this with ukrainians correct so he was
trying to lay the pretext of in my you
know why would he do that the only
logical reason for the Russians to do
that is because they're trying to set
the stage for saying hey these
biological weapons are coming out it
ain't us it's the U.S and the ukrainians
releasing it and so and we were
concerned about that a lot it was
written on that and well pushed back
saying hey this is nonsense but why
wouldn't the US be doing it why wouldn't
we do we want building bio labs to make
uh weapons well we signed the treaties
saying we would not use biological
weapons and warfare and I think and I
think we're we're following that but you
know I think it's very probable that
Trump could do that and he could be
doing it tomorrow well if you remember
in Ukraine the U.S corporate media and
political establishment first said
there's no bio weapons there's no
bio-lab facilities in Ukraine and then
the Secretary of State under assistant
secretary came out and said uh there's
medical facilities in Ukraine we've got
to get to immediately before the
Russians get to and everyone's like yeah
we're doing research there what kind of
research gain of function research
trying to take a virus and make it the
most lethal the most dangerous virus
that we can in the name of science even
though many scientists argued that there
hasn't been any gain of function done
for any kind of scientific discovery but
predominantly done to uh have bio
weapons out there so when you look at
you know the United States uh Barack
Obama banned gain of function research
Donald Trump for some reason allowed it
to happen and that's when Dr fauci Peter
dazek Echo Health Alliance went to Wuhan
China and then started to do the covid
back coronavirus research there now
they're doing it again under Joe Biden
but now they're doing it Myanmar Laos in
Vietnam again Peter dazek doing gain of
function research on covid coronavirus I
don't know if you've heard of these but
but this is something eye opening and of
course there was also similar gain of
function research being done in Ukraine
as well well let me for a second defend
the gain of function research as I've
already you know attacked it but the
reason we do it is is also avian flu is
naturally mutating all the time every
virus does and biologists have been
warning us for a long time now
Congressional testimony even saying
avian flu will probably mutate to be
human human transmissible even if humans
aren't screwing around with it trying to
deliberately do that so that's why we're
doing the gain of function research on
the avian flu it is eventually going to
develop I mean swine flu comes to pigs
develops mutates but we're not talking
about that what's going to happen so
they're doing the gain of function
research because we want to have a human
human transmissible form of avian flu
now so we can develop vaccines for it
that's why they're doing it that's a
legitimate reason that could I could
understand the argument for but that's
not what they're doing they're doing
coronavirus bat research that has no
probability of ever uh realizing in real
life because of natural circumstances
right
yeah so uh I have the suite from Tulsi
gabbard calling out Victoria Newland
saying quote Ukraine has biological
research facilities which in fact we are
quite concerned that Russian troops may
be seeking to gain control of we are
working with ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those research materials
from falling into the hands of Russian
forces should they approach so the issue
now becomes Trust
we have a quote from Victoria Newland
that there are biological research
facilities in Ukraine that uh there was
a dude
um emails released from the hunter Biden
laptop which were confirmed by The Daily
Mail in the New York Post that he was
working on getting some funding which
went to I think it went to a third party
and then to these Labs I don't think he
was directly working with the labs but
you know now we're making now we're
talking semantics the question is am I
supposed to just trust the us as the one
not doing this and Putin of course is
the is the unrepentant evil who is doing
it or am I supposed to look at this and
look at this and just be like it's War
the US would be insane not to be engaged
in researching Advanced Weaponry defense
systems vaccines or whatever and uh why
wouldn't Russia as well and at the very
least why would I assume that they have
these biological research facilities
with dangerous pathogens and they're not
understanding that whether the intention
of the researchers make a weapon that
weapons can arise from this I mean to go
back to nuclear weapons the 1938 uh
paper on you know nuclear fission wasn't
a paper on how to make nuclear bombs but
they saw and went we can make a bomb
with that so the research they're doing
here in Ukraine with these biofacilities
they could be like hey if we release
that it's a weapon right
yeah I do not believe the United States
is developing biological weapons some
you know there's a lot of people like to
spread conspiracy theories in in
government I was well hold on hold on
what's a weapon a weapon is something
designed to be used to kill your enemy
so I think we're doing gain of function
research for legitimate reasons so we've
got the bad virus so we can develop via
vaccines for it antidotes treatment
methods and understanding
I get that but is dynamite a weapon uh
can be used that way correct can any
gain of function pathogen be used as a
weapon yes it can be in the US
a weapon program no of the United States
well now you're let's say you're arguing
intent and we can't read anybody's mind
so the question is when Alfred Nobel
he's the guy who made dynamite right and
then they call them The Merchant of
death it was intended I believe for
mining you can you can put it well then
you can mine instead it started being
used as a weapon which was not his
intention nuclear fission same thing was
not intended to make a bomb and a bomb
out of it if the U.S has Labs that are
making dangerous pathogens it's not a
question of whether or not you we could
we can argue the semantics over it's
weaponized or a weapon or the intent was
to make it a weapon the fact of the
matter is the U.S has labs in Ukraine
that are dealing with and advancing
dangerous pathogens well I don't know
what danger what they were working on
there was a dangerous pathogen or not
that every country around the world has
biological research the crispr
technology the bioengineering technology
it's all over the world there's no
turning back the clock the ability to to
either by the way that I don't get into
the details but the way to make avian
flu is not a high-tech crispr technology
it's low-tech any any Unabomber
terrorist any small terrorist group
could do this you don't need high-tech
biology stuff to make avian flu mammal
to mammal human limit just real quick
real quick real quick if a guy was
making dynamite in his garage would we
say he's not making weapons
uh no he could be using it for good or
bad purpose we don't know what he's
doing it is but he builds a lab to make
dynamite he's going to get arrested and
charged it's inevitable that we are
going to have pandemics I had an article
published in the American interest back
in 2016 called the age of bioengineered
pandemics and collapse because we cannot
stop this it is going to happen either
there's natural mutations but there's so
many people with this technology it's so
widespread so relatively easy to do that
it is going to happen and experts have
testified before Congress warning is
going to happen but has Congress done
anything nothing just as they've done
nothing about our Electric System there
was a congressionally funded EMP study
decades ago saying that our Electric
System is our Achilles heel it's very
vulnerable even even North Korea with
one inaccurate low-yield nuclear weapon
could take down the U.S Electric System
for over a year there's a documentary
out right now called grid down power up
that gives you all the explanation of
how our Electric System is a disaster
waiting to happen that any enemy could
exploit to take us down and the estimate
from that Congressional study was that
when the electric grid goes down and
they're talking about an EMP event that
takes out the Transformers that take a
long time very difficult to replace the
estimate was you could lose 90 percent
of the U.S population dead not just
because of you know there's no
electricity there's there's no food
production there's no water systems also
because people aren't just going to you
know stay at home and you know quietly
politely die they're going to go out to
steal food and water to survive you'll
have massive loss of Law and Order
massive marauding and people are going
to get killed they're estimates you
could lose 90 percent of the population
so Congress knows about that they know
about bioweapons threat the Johns
Hopkins biological experts have
testified over and over before Congress
warning about avian flu warning about
bioengineering but there's no votes in
prevention and preparedness they don't
do anything about it and so we're left
in the the position where there's
another documentary by uh it was vice
called while the rest of us die so
they've gotten Mountain weather they've
got they've got Raven Rock all these
places they can survive but the rest of
us there's nothing being done for us
it's not far away uh I have a million
things I want to bring up right now that
I have jotted down so hopefully I'll get
to all of them I think the United States
military industrial complex would be
foolish not to develop weapons that
other countries are developing as well I
think from a strategic point of view it
wouldn't make sense for the United
States not to engage in this uh you said
a lot of the research is being done to
help people to prevent and create
vaccines but the United States had an
official biological weapons program
where they weaponized Anthrax Q fever
and many others previously before why
would they stop now what evidence do you
have that they stopped and as we
previously as we previously mentioned
you said that the United States is doing
this to help people this gain of
functions to help people but uh we just
talked about the the covid Coronavirus
why were they doing that research when
there was no natural ability for that
virus to to be realized in human life
why were they officially doing that
project when there was no particular
need for it
let me do the first part I mean we have
stopped developing biological weapons we
won signed the treaty saying we wouldn't
and our government is largely full of
good people who do you know the right
thing we don't have a biological
question I'm sorry
number two before you you know so the
other number two thing is we have
nuclear weapons so if Putin does release
a biological weapon against us and we
know it's Putin can prove its Putin our
responses will nuke the hell out of you
you can't prove it that's well we might
be able to no I mean I mean if that's
our policy that's the others when we
give a biological weapons is we have
nuclear weapons but we signed that
treaty biological weapons against us The
Logical use responses will nuke the hell
out of you is is the is the EU in any
way working on biological weapons uh
probably not what if uh the U.S you're
right they are abiding by this treaty
and so in fact the bio weapons research
was happening in a country like Ukraine
which is not a NATO or EU member State
well soon to be our government said they
weren't and I do trust our government
when they said the Ukraine was not doing
a biological weapons what about chemical
weapons well the security the Secretary
of State under secretary officially
launched that there's biological
research facilities in Ukraine why would
the United States not do that program
domestically why would they choose a
poor country that's known for corruption
to do scientific experiments that are
known to be dangerous that that that
sounds the alarms to a lot of people who
are saying this is circumstantial
evidence that they're doing this
biological dangerous research in their
country not to have any Fallout or
responsibility here in the United States
dangerous pathogens are there that's
what Victoria Newland said biological
research facilities are there Russian
troops are trying to get in control of
it there's dangerous pathogens they're
at these Labs all of that is according
to the US government true and correct
now whether or not you want to argue
it's a weapon or not is the intent of
the person behind it and if you can't
read their mind what's the point yeah
this is the thing about white phosphorus
they use the American Military used in
Fallujah in 2004 they called it an
incendiary they said the purpose of this
weapon is to light up the battlefield so
we can see people but what they don't
say is that the white phosphorus was
also melting the skin of the civilians
that it was lighting up so they said hey
Our intention wasn't to hurt people so
it's not a weapon it's an it's just a
lighting up mechanism yeah but it was
also an incendiary weapon so just
because you call it research for
prevention doesn't mean that it's not
also potentially going to wipe out the
population I don't even care about the
term research if they are doing gaino
function research they are producing
dangerous pathogens period now whether
or not look like I mentioned Alfred
Nobel was shocked to discover he was The
Merchant of death when his obituary was
accidentally published was he an
inventor of a powerful weapon I don't
think that was his intention and that's
why he came out was like I got to do
this Peace Prize thing but again if if
somebody if AI if the US government said
we're going to be doing we're going to
be built putting a bunch of plants that
build explosives we would call that
weapons research yeah the word weapon is
a pejorative right and or you know just
tell them explosives call them
biological pathogens call them chemical
agents you know but whether or not
they're weapons is irrelevantages my
point is there could be someone in the
US government who says hey you know what
the U.S government uh needs explosives
for construction mining clearing debris
so we're going to create a bunch of
factories that make a variety of
explosives that guy does that the next
guy comes in and says hey you got a
bunch of weapons here I can use so we
can argue about the definition of women
weapon but the fact is the US is making
dangerous gain a function pathogens if
someone at any point decides to
weaponize them that'll be on them but
they exist and they can be weaponized
right I think uh it's kind of Simone the
situation in Lebanon when you had all
the build up of that fertilizer the fact
of the matter was and so Time Bomb
waiting to happen waiting for a spark
you know I think no matter what there
still is fertilizer building up there
still is a situation that's arising and
it's only a matter of time before
something kicks off that causes a you
know a Calamity you can expect I just
mean to say it doesn't really matter if
there's a person you know twirling their
mustache being like we're making bio
weapons because they are like yeah we're
advancing dangerous pathogens but don't
worry it's not for weaponizing it's like
well a bad person can get them a bad
person can get elected a bad person can
get promoted a bad person can force
their way in and then there's no I think
you know
I'm not trying to drag research I
understand like you make a good point
the gain of function has has a real
purpose the problem is that technology
is neutral and bad people will do bad
things so I don't like to jump out and
be like they're making weapons as much
as I'd like to say they're not making
weapons no they're making dangerous
things exactly it can be weapons
remember when they were like Assad is
gassing his own people we need to invade
you know come on guys keep your eyes
open for Putin is dropping new uh
biological agents on his own people but
he's doing it in Ukraine first come on
guys yeah I wanna I wanna I wanna jump
to this this I guess you can call it a
story this tweet from interactive polls
breaking NASDAQ Falls to two year low on
Monday minus 1.84 s p lost 1.2 look at
this picture I mean there's some green
in there okay it's not as bad as that
that image of when Joe Biden was raising
his fists and then people put the
collapsing Market behind them all in red
as that Meme that was that was a good
meme but we're not a two-year low now
and the stock market is dropped below
the levels it was at before Biden became
president so I don't want to make this
one political I want to make this one
this segment talk about the collapse of
the economy more personal for
individuals and uh ask you know ask you
drew as we are watching an academic
downturn we're seeing inflation we're
seeing gas prices now go up my question
is if this trajectory continues for
whatever reason be it the war or
whatever what happens to the average
person's life you know so you know you
as somebody who runs fortitude Ranch
this Recreation and survivalist
Community you you had to have done all
the research and your your middle of the
class nuclear family economy hits what
does their life look like and how bad
can it get well you know a lot of people
are calling for the recession so there
there could be losses of jobs coming
although thus far that hasn't really
happened higher prices but the thing
that's really going to hurt people next
year is food prices not just because of
normal inflation everywhere but because
of the lack of fertilizer since they
come largely from the Ukraine and Russia
and we're not getting those and there's
there's predictions and not just hire
food prices but in some parts of the
world you're going to have famine next
year because food production is going to
be way way down food prices are going to
go way up and there's been other
contributing factors a stupid government
policies trying to stop fertilized use
in some ways for environmental reasons
but we're the world is facing a bad
famine situation next year assuming
something worse doesn't happen like put
releasing a virus this year or nuclear
war or whatever so uh
the average family somebody who I assume
the average person they don't really pay
attention you know I was thinking we
were talking about the war stuff I was
like why don't people care about care
about this more why are there so many
people that we try and talk about I
don't care about war you know what's
going on who I don't even know who that
is what you can't wear is it and then
I'm sitting here you know listening to
Luke talk about the variety of things
the US is engaged in what Russia is
doing and I'm thinking to myself this is
the kind of stuff that if you don't know
about one day it smacks you in the face
that the war erupts the food shortages
the food prices for the people that have
been paying attention and have done some
degree of preparation
they're in a much better position so
with that with that in mind let's say
this escalates to hyperinflation let's
say it does something bad happens let's
say it's either a nuclear strike let's
say it's a virus or something happens
the average person in the United States
what do you think their day is like when
the grid gets hit or when when when gas
price gases are gone or what happens in
the worst case scenario well it's bad
news for them I mean government's top
priority is protecting government and
that's that's official policy it's
called continuity of government and any
kind of disaster or collapse
um your police protection will go down
uh because number one the priority is to
protect the elected officials the Mayors
the governors everyone else so police
normally doing Patrols in your
neighborhood some of them will be called
back to increase protection and care for
government officials I mean you're near
Mount weather here I won't give out your
exact location but you're not far from
Mount weather I drove by there about a
month ago I can't believe all the
construction going on right
they've already got massive facilities
and they're expanding them for
government officials but there's nothing
done for civil defenses gone in the
United States and there's nothing being
done and the thing that makes me the
Madison there's not even the warnings uh
government should be issuing warnings to
people about situations like the coming
food price jump that we're going to
experience the likelihood of famine
because of the again the Russia Ukraine
situation and it just doesn't happen
there's there's not care for us it's all
about you know current issues and
winning votes and you know debates that
relative to life and death are trivial
all right my favorite city in all this
New York City what happens when the when
the grid gets hit when the food stops
flowing uh it'll be it'll be there used
to be a saying in the preparedness
industry you know 48 hours to animal you
know in 48 hours it takes 40 hours for
people to realize how bad it's getting
and then they turn into their animal
instincts and they would kill to survive
I think it's more today probably more
like 48 seconds or 48 minutes to animal
because people are aware now that when
the grid goes down for example again you
ought to watch grid down Power Up
documentary when the grid goes down
immediately there is no water system
flowing so people are going to start
filling their bathtubs everyone does
that so within five minutes Waters
Municipal Water is gone there's no value
if everyone starts filling your bathtub
and there's no pumping going on the
system shut down so there's three days
suits applying an average Supermarket
that'll be gone in the first hour or two
people are going to run to the grocery
store they're either going to pay or
more likely to just start looting people
and I think violence will start in the
first hours people stealing and
potentially killing to survive because
they're going to figure out hey there's
no way you can survive in New York City
without an electric system right there's
a bad pandemic I disagree uh we were
there like you were Luke you were there
during Sandy right yeah yeah the power
was gone for like two weeks in in like
like Lower East Side I think I think it
was a couple days out in the upper west
side where all the rich people were is
that what it was Luke was like 72 hours
something yeah uh Staten Island got hit
really hard
um and parts of lower Manhattan got
flooded as well as some parts of
Brooklyn and it wasn't you know it
wasn't Calamity wasn't too crazy but but
Staten Island dudes the boat was on the
street it was nuts the issue was that uh
they could still bring food in there was
still gas there were still cars that's
localized so I'm talking about you know
a national loss of the Electric System
and National you know pandemic that's
all over the place so this is what what
I mean to say is when people have faith
the government exists Aid is coming
they're chill but if something happens
where people their confidence has to be
rocked so my view is I don't know about
the first hour I think a lot of people
the smart people maybe not even
necessarily smart but the more Cutthroat
they're going to go out and they're
going to get whatever they can as fast
as they can I think most people in New
York are going to be looking around
confused and just shrug I got to tell
you man I love telling that story of
when I worked for Fusion and the fire
alarm went off and everybody just sat
around staring at it as soon as I went I
got up and left the building and then
the people only left the building when
the fire department actually ran in with
their gear that's the average person
the Grid's gonna go down they're going
oh the power is out I gotta tell you
this and a second story I was in a uh
working for fusion and I'm in New York
and the power goes out and the alarms go
on saying everyone remain calm and
remain in the building and I was like no
thanks and I left I'm like it was uh
apparently there was a flood there was
there was a leak that hit something
electrical and created a huge risk of
fire but they were like no no everyone
stay calm just just keep doing your
thing I'm not sticking around for that I
think what's going to happen in cities
like New York
something bad's really going to happen
and the average person doesn't read the
news doesn't watch the news doesn't pay
attention and if they do it's it's
through really bad sources who are lying
to them and so they're going to sit
there and they're gonna be told hey
everybody the economy is going to be
fine just stay home for the day
a day goes by the food's gone the
water's gone the economy's gone their
money's worthless these people are going
to lose it they're either I mean most of
these people are probably going to get
the maraud is going to come for them
these people don't seem the kind of
people who are going to be able to
survive but some of these guys are going
to just go around and become Marauders
poor NPCs I don't know there's a lot of
obese people in the United States I
think they have a lot of extra fat that
they're going to of course depend on and
uh I'll think they're probably going to
TiVo American Gladiators or some sports
balls and and then let their fat little
you know little way and start some
fasting that that's not by their choice
but but obviously it all depends on
there's a number of scenarios happening
I I wanted to ask you drew from from all
your work especially with intelligence
what do you think is the most likely
scenario and situation especially after
coming out of covid that that could lead
to the worst case scenario what do you
think is the most impactful the most
likely situation well at 40 Ranch we
actually track 50 we call them trigger
events that could lead to a collapse and
the ones that we rate is you know
ignoring Ukraine right now in the
current situation but overall we rank a
pandemic a really bad pandemic is the
most likely uh event that's going to
happen and you know we've had biologists
warning us so we're actually overdue for
a really bad pandemic they tend to the
the influenza ones tend to come in
Cycles we're kind of overdue for that
and it's so easy to do man-made and it's
so likely that a country like North
Korea or Iran you know where the great
Saiyan to Iran and again you know will
the virus spread back to the country
releases it yes but before I release the
virus I can develop vaccines and Destiny
so it won't hurt me when it come back or
it won't hurt the people I care about in
my country if I'm Iran or North Korea I
disagree and I'll tell you why here's
what I think would happen be it Iran
Russia North Korea China or anybody
Corporation they will release the virus
in their own country first but a weaker
strain of it it will it will have a low
mortality which will result in some
death but most of the people will just
get sick and then get over it stop
giving them ideas it's not giving an
idea this is what happened with uh
Spanish flu China many people uh I was
reading about the history like why
didn't China get hit by this in fact
they did before everyone else did a
weaker a weaker strain but a similar
strain swept across China many of them
got very very sick when the Spanish Flu
that emerges I think it was in like it
was in the United States but then it was
seen in Europe during with all the
fighting so that's how ability how it
got its name when this starts spreading
it does make its way back to China but
they already had immunity to it from the
weaker virus that had hit them so I
think what would actually happen is a
smart country produces two versions a
very weak version and a very strong
version they give themselves the weak
version first then the strong version is
released so when it does come and hit
them mortality is minimal but the point
is this technology this ability has
never existed before in human history
it's out there now there's all kinds of
forms that could happen with and you
know the experts use the word inevitable
we are going to have these kinds of
pandemics but but back to your question
Luke it's not just pandemics the other
really big one likely one is our fragile
Electric System because it's vulnerable
in so many ways we've been talking about
you know a nuclear EMP attack and North
Korea's nuclear weapons this is open
source this is some classified
information the Russians help them
actually as Soviets before Russia help
them design nuclear weapons that are
designed for maximum EMP effect they
don't have to be accurate they go off in
our atmosphere one or two and the U.S
electric grid is toast at that point
there's Cyber attack that could take
down the grit there's physical attacks
and they've been done there was an
attack out at a station in California a
very well carried out attack that
destroyed the Transformers there Cyber
attack uh no physical attack there's a
lot of solar flares natural effects can
take down our electric grid that's again
you've got to watch this documentary
grid down power up there's so many ways
our fragile Electric System could go and
when I say go it's gone for over a year
or more and most Americans will not be
alive when if it comes back up we'll be
dead I think we've been hit by cyber
attacks but we haven't recently and you
just don't hear about it a lot of there
was a there was one story it was highly
speculative I know I know I'm just
saying just a thought
it was around the time that Donald Trump
was an airstrike was on its way to Iran
Trump calls it off and says no publicly
he says I did not think that you know
500 people who would have died the loss
of life was was worth what we would be
retaliating for something that effect
however around the same time that the
U.S launches this this this Fleet to go
to an airstrike a refinery in
Philadelphia explodes
I asked some of my uh my hacker buddies
do you think there's a that what what is
the what is the likelihood that in
response to the US engaging in military
operation Iran
used it conducted a Cyber attack against
a Refinery blowing it up and we know
they did it so we backed off they told
me it was very very low not very likely
um however possible but just not at all
likely they they all basically said no
no no no no way no way no way lottery
tickets chance but possible sure I guess
so my thing is that was just one example
of a scenario where I see this and I'm
like could it have been at the Cyber
attack blew up the uh the petroleum
Refinery so then Trump's seeing that
vulnerability cancels the attack knowing
it's going to lead to a greater
escalation in cyber warfare maybe maybe
not again I'll stress my expert buddy
said they don't think that was the case
based on how it went down but thinking
about that there have been many
circumstances where we've seen various
industrial facilities get you know have
fires start abruptly and the answer is
sometimes fires start are we hyper
focused on this and now we're assuming
it's going to be a Cyber attack or are
we in a normalcy bias that we cannot see
that we are actually under attack when
we are how would we even know
and then there's there's a lot more
threats to um the the threat of
nanotechnology some new technologies we
keep coming out with you know you were
talking Earl about unintended
consequences a lot of people working
with nanotechnology are concerned about
that Elon Musk is always talking about
artificial intelligence and and I think
the artificial intelligence threat is
very much there but not in the normal
way you see in a movie where the
computer becomes you know thinking and
evil the bigger thought from artificial
intelligence is some terrorist group or
a nation you know North Korea has
tremendous cyber capability actually
programming and releasing a virus you
know instructing computers maximize
human death through the means you've got
that kind of a system of doing it but
there's many other sources that that
could lead to disaster Beyond pandemics
or vulnerable Electric System zombies
other new technologies
what's the over on under on zombies and
civil war Civil War is a big one and so
it's just going to mention one Another
Thing Ray dalio is you know either it's
either not seem Talib or Ray Dali or
probably the two smartest people alive I
know of today he's the founder of
Bridgewater the most successful hedge
fund in history yeah we got to get Ray
Daley on the show he'll be amazing on
the show so he has estimated recently
there's a 30 percent likelihood of war
with China in the near future that's his
estimate he's a China expert and he's
also said he sees the 30 chance of civil
war after the next presidential election
he says you know the these are not
calculated numbers back to your earlier
question these are guesstimates but he's
a very wise man a hedge fund you know is
makes a success based on trying to
understand how the world is how things
are developing so again on trigger
events 30 percent chance of a war with
China that could be a nuclear war with
nuclear strikes on the Homeland that
leads to a collapse because our society
is so fragile so government dependent
and there's just a lot of bad people and
one other thing that I've never seen
this anywhere in print or in the media
but a huge threat and vulnerability we
Face the United States is the 1.5
million Americans in jail one and a half
million Americans in jail so when
there's a pandemic a 60 lethal pandemic
do you think guards are going to go to
work and risk they're not going to go to
work if the electric grid goes down how
do prisons work I used to be a county
commissioner I've been in jails jails
cannot function without electricity
that's how you control all the doors
it's all electric well they open or they
stay locked they're probably going to
come open I mean there's a generator
backup hospitals will claim oh we've got
generator backup they've got back up for
maybe three days at the most that's a
good thing so you can have one and a
half million Americans most of our bad
criminals but a lot of them are who are
in jail and they have absolutely no
preparedness they've got no house
they've got no food so when they get out
of their jails either released or they
just get out on their own what are they
going to do they're going to maraud it's
the only way they're going to stay alive
they don't don't have a house they don't
have home and food and water they've got
to go out and steal from other people
probably kill them in the process to
survive well I kind of talks about that
I got to say our government is not
getting us prepared well for events that
experts are say are inevitable I I
disagree on the prison thing though
prisons would be one of the safest and
most secure places to remain so if if
you're there you've got a bunch of guys
you've already got gangs so if if
there's no more guards there might be a
lot of infighting if that is the case
the end result is going to be someone
who owns a fortress now they may go in
Murad but they're going to use the
prison as like a fortress base of
operations and control it and there's
weapons in there so they are instantly
going to be armed armored and determined
and have facilities and it's it's going
to be night it's it's look I'll say it's
worse than you're you're predicting
prisoners will get out and go Murad
they're gonna have a fortress base of
operations with weapons and then you
know they're gonna go out and go on
their patrols and you probably I mean
maybe you'll notice they're wearing
prison clothes but it's not going to
matter guys with guns are going to come
up and say you work for us now we
control this massive fortification so
you can't even get to us if you wanted
to that's the worst scenario that I had
imagine let me let me ask you about this
though you mentioned driving past Mount
weather and so I looked up this story
from the from the US Sun ready for nuke
Armageddon inside Doomsday Bunkers
designed by U.S government to withstand
nuclear apocalypse and restart America
in case of Wipeout
they say the U.S government built
several doomsday nuclear look at these
pictures why are they why would they
even show anybody this is Cheyenne
Mountain can withstand a 30 Megaton
nuclear bomb oh okay so you mean it
can't withstand the the Satan II missile
what's the point thanks for telling us I
gotta tell you I see these videos I'm
sorry I see these photos these stories
about Mount weather am I really supposed
to believe that Raven Rock Mount weather
these facilities are the legitimate
facilities for our government when we
all know they exist and 30 megatons is
that it come on sarbama was a hundred at
full capacity not that they're going to
get a bomber over it you know but taking
on underground four to five facilities
90s you have to tremendously good
accuracy I grew up in Lincoln Nebraska
60 miles from Offutt Air Force Base
Strategic Air Command uh headquarters
you know one of the top nuclear targets
and I remember reading one day that the
the uh I the the accuracy of Russian
Soviet missiles was about 50 miles
although that's great they're going to
aim it off and they're going to hit me
in Lincoln they're not that accurate now
that's proved a lot our weapons have
improved a lot but when was the last
time we even detonated a nuclear weapon
it's been about 30 years we got rid of
underground nuclear testing so for a
nuclear weapon to go and take out
something like Mount weather it'd have
to be very very accurate weapon would
have to have you know its full yield but
why and they're probably not going to
have that accuracy so I think they will
survive in Mountain no I'm saying
they've got to have other bunkers we
don't know but they have a lot of them
their site R there's quite a few in
Pennsylvania again you guys are kind of
in a bad place for nuclear weapons here
I I disagree David you got the Pentagon
you got DC you got malweather you got
sidear I don't think they're not that
accurate so if they're aiming at them
they could end up landing on you I think
well first before we get into the new
stuff I want to ask you about driving
past Mount weather they're doing
construction there oh a lot of it and I
said that's above ground and most of
it's underground so I can't imagine
what's going on underground so it's
already been a huge FEMA facility we
gotta get some reporting on this we got
to send somebody to go interview
something to get disappeared you mean
there's lightly request an interview
the government is very secretive
especially about their other facilities
that they don't talk about that there's
no pictures of that there's no talk
about uh there's no talking about
there's a lot of underground facilities
that the United States has been
investing in there's a reason the
Pentagon has secret clandestine black
budgets there's a reason why so much
money is missing from the federal
coffers because a lot of times they're
spending it on a lot of top secret
projects that are underground facilities
that they have already implemented that
no one even knows about like black sites
yeah and black though well the black
sites are in Egypt and Poland and other
places around the world some torture
people but that's a different scenario
I'm interested in Mount weather it's
very close to where we are and so what
what's what's the gist of this can you
tell us the basic like what is it sure
it's an underground shelter uh FEMA
defends it on the surface and the
military troops will be there as well
but it's a place where congressmen will
go it's fairly close to DC so they can
whisk them off there and they've got
fantastic facilities they even have
media rooms so the congressman can
continue to you know transmit to their
constituents and you know not lose votes
if there's another election I guess but
they have fantastic facilities where
they'll stay alive and nothing is done
for the rest of us you know we're don't
even give us warning hey you might want
to do your own preparations things are
kind of bad oh no no that's just for
them the modern left mocks those who
would be prepared for even a rainy day
it's it's amazing we've got these these
hurricanes these floods but it is it is
a joke it's it's
it is common Urban culture to mock
Preppers to assume that anybody who's
prepared in any way is some lunatic
mountain man when you know I was in uh I
was in Arizona a couple years ago and I
was doing the toilet paper conflict
everyone's fighting over toilet paper I
go to a gas station and some lady you
know I said like how has it been out
here and she's like this is the middle
of nowhere Arizona's like a weird little
rest stop and she's like oh we're good
we're Preppers so we've got like three
months worth of toilet paper already so
we haven't noticed anything and I
started laughing and I was like you know
what while they're all fighting in
Walmart over toilet paper they're making
fun of you for having it it's the
craziest thing yeah well the the image
of Preppers and preparedness has
improved a lot over the past couple of
years it was partly covid-19 but was
really less coveted 19 than things like
Portland and all the unrest that was
going on people saw how if people start
protesting start looting police cannot
stop it I'm not criticizing police there
just aren't many of them compared to
people if a lot of people start breaking
the law start looting start doing
whatever they they want to do you cannot
stop them so people have realized that
you know you really do need preparedness
people can get out of control can do
violence and you cannot put it down
there's not enough police or even
military folks to do that one of the
funniest things ever was when the
pandemic started and a bunch of liberals
were lining up outside of gun stores to
buy guns for the first time and the best
thing to emerge from it was the gun
store I think it was in California where
they were like the guy makes a video
saying stop complaining to me about why
you can't buy a gun you voted for this
you all voted for it people people come
to the gun store thinking they can buy a
gun and then walk out of the store with
it they can't they gotta come back three
days later and they're freaking out like
what why like there's a pandemic there's
no food I need I need to protect myself
well too bad you voted for it that's why
I like States like West Virginia
conceal a constitutional carry you walk
in you got to fill out your federal
background check but uh you know the
first time you do it I think everyone
I've seen the first time they've tried
they've been held up a little bit for a
day or a couple days but then after that
it's like you walk in you can get it you
can carry it right out conceal it and
whatever and take care of yourself and
you can defend yourself so I feel like
New York City is going to be
man I don't even know I don't think any
movies any movie or any fiction has done
apocalypse justice as to what I think
would actually happen in a city like New
York in central Brooklyn where in the
first day when a collapse happens nobody
has any idea what's going on they have
food in their fridge it starts running
out they go and look around people are
confused by the second day all the
food's probably gone taken within a few
days anything that was perishable has
perished there's some canned goods left
and now people are really hungry and
really thirsty and looking around
wondering what's going on
So What by then the smart people have
all left and the people who aren't smart
and have been confused this whole time
what eat each other drink blood well
there is a much much bigger and better
awareness of preparedness in the US over
the past years I mean that's absolutely
clear we cannot keep up with the demand
we get people every day emailing us
asking for information wanting to join
and we just fall further and further
behind we can't meet the demand that's
why 14 Ranch has started franchising now
we can't build enough to keep up so
we're franchising now so if you that's
kind of crazy you've got a survival
Community or if you've got an RV park
you got a ranch and you think hey I
could have a nice survival facility here
you can now build one and we will help
you do it through our franchise abroad
because we can't keep up we also can't
keep up with hiring so we're looking for
more folks if an interested in working
on our staff are the staff of a
franchisee you know if you want to
contact fortitude ranch.com at our
website we're looking for more people
but we can't keep up with demand but
that's one of the point I wanted to make
is the other reason why preparedness has
had a bad image is is that stupid show
Doomsday Preppers which made Preppers
look like idiots when the reason they
did that is the first rule of prepping
is don't tell anyone you're a prepper
you keep it a secret you don't want
people to know hey I got a lot of guns
and food and ammo at my house if there's
a pandemic or the grids down they're
going to come to your house or chickens
either to bed yeah you keep that
confidential so no one is going to go on
a TV show and say hey I'm a prepper
here's all my preparations here's what
I've got they only had idiots on that
show that show really hurt preparedness
smart people are Preppers it's insurance
it's a life insurance policy not to pay
you if you die but to keep you alive so
our members are very smart people
they're electric professionals yeah we
got a lot of former military we have
some intelligence officials but largely
it's you know it's business people and
people who are smart and educated and
they don't talk about it they keep it
confidential but the demand is growing
growing growing and we can't keep up so
we're looking for more wisdom of the
crowd how many how many government
officials do you have contacting you for
your services and and guilty pleasure I
really like that show that you mentioned
because it was really fun to watch
um but not not strategic but but it was
fun to see
uh well government officials don't need
us again they've got that I mean even
even at the state level you know the
state patrol provides protection for the
government in the normal course of Duty
and they'll do a lot more when there's a
collapse what about government employees
oh we have government employees we have
people from Homeland Security from the
Pentagon at our West Virginia location
does that does that does it seem like
there's more of them more more people
work for the government than other
sectors no most of our members are some
business professionals is probably our
most common category we have a lot of
doctors now that's the other than
covid-19 change for us as a medical
community really got hold of
preparedness wow we used to be it used
to be a sometimes we would have our time
getting doctors and we had four doctors
at 40 Ranch Colorado I don't need four
doctors there but a lot of them have
joined since the pandemic well you guys
are franchising how does that work how
do you get involved with someone that
has space that wants to become a
franchisee oh I think on our website
there's information on it but basically
we're going to provide you the training
the operations manual help you design
your facility and make it possible for
you to be be part of the 14 Ranch system
and you will be part of our system
because our system is again we're a
survival committee but we're also a
recreational facility so you can be a
member in West Virginia but you can go
to our lake property in Wisconsin you
come to a high mountain desert in Nevada
come to Texas and you know go to San
Antonio and the attractions down there
it's a vacation place too so you have a
home Fort where your stuff is and where
you try to get in a collapse but again
if you're if you're a West Virginia
member but you know you're doing the Tim
show out in California and the [ __ ] hits
the fan and you can't get back to West
Virginia you can go to Nevada and we'll
take care of you there and a franchise
would be the same way you're part of the
system so your members have the right to
you know they'd be home 40 at your place
but they could use any of the Forty
Ranch facilities but if things get bad
you got to go work in the field oh
absolutely our members understand that
you know it's a vacation place you know
come out shoot weapons have fun and good
times and bad times we will work you
very hard everyone will do guard Duty
and we got a lot of work to do we'll be
be cutting down trees building our walls
improving our defenses slaughtering
animals we'll be poaching massively I
mean if you're a deer near us when the
[ __ ] hits the fan we will be shooting
you and making jerky out of you so what
about expanding the territory and
seizing the land from the from the
surrounding uh we don't do that we're
strictly uh strictly a defensive motion
we're now Steve Renee our CEO has been
on your shift several times and I know
he's pointed out we are not an offensive
militia we're not a militia if there are
good militia groups don't get me wrong
but we are not one we don't do anything
offensive we defend our private property
in a collab but but let's let's say
we're now you know five years into a
collapse the surrounding homes have all
been abandoned you gotta have Scout
patrols go out and start looking for
seeing what's going on and you know they
I imagine you guys would not be
offensive but what if there's abandoned
land you need it for grazing or
expansion because now you got more
people are coming or you've signed on
more or Village members I suppose or
let's say it's even 15 20 years you're
gonna have more people more kids you're
gonna need to expand it's uh well I
actually haven't thought that through to
be honest with you but you know we're
hoping that uh the recovery would start
within a year or two if it's a really
bad pandemic and eventually we're hoping
that some Law and Order will return uh
but if not you know we'd have to deal
with whatever it is that's why all of
our Ranch Management of our former
military officers and enlisted folks who
have good background and good judgment
and then our membership is this is
really well educated good people so
we've got a core of people you know 100
plus people at every location so we
could do whatever we need to do in a
responsible manner to survive and then
to recover after things improve two more
questions about the franchising one it's
um it's for-profit the company's
for-profit yes um and then if someone
opens up a franchisee location are they
doing all the hiring and taking all the
profits themselves or are you guys
supplying the funds for them to do
hiring and then you take a cut they're a
private business the only difference is
you know unlike a typical franchise
where you know your customers are kind
of your customers if you joined 40 Ranch
you're part of the whole system that's
kind of a key Advantage we offer is
again you may not be able to get back to
your own fort you may want to Vacation
another location so members are all in
one system but it is your your property
your 14 Ranch location your business you
hire you fire you Superman do you pay
like a franchise licensing fee or
something yes or a franchise fee to join
and then a percent of royalties like any
other franchise cool but then when the
apocalypse happens you have a network
correct and so I'd imagine if you know
one one location is starting to suffer
the other locations can provide
assistance uh we'll be uh would be up on
ham radio so we've got our frequencies
and times a day that you know at this
time and this night we're on this
frequency so we can connect so for
example back to the doctors we've got I
mean we've got like you know cancer
experts at some place we've got OB GYN
you know birthing doctors at another but
at night mainly use HF radio at night
with better bouncing off the signal so
at night you know the doctors can confer
so we can do that kind of in terms of
physical assistance during a collapse no
probably not a 14 inch is pretty much
going to be on their own you got to
hunker down and there's probably going
to be no outside contact I want to jump
to this story did you have another
question you want to ask you said no no
that was it let's jump to the story from
Insider and get into the to the meat
potatoes here this PayPal story Insider
reports PayPal Falls after weekend
blowback over misinformation policy that
would find users twenty five hundred
dollars the stock fell six percent on
Monday following the company's botched
acceptable use policy update the company
faced backlash after its updated policy
included a fine of twenty five hundred
dollars for a variety of things but it
included hate speech against
marginalized groups and spreading
misinformation and it said at PayPal's
sole discretion to determine meaning
they could just be like you said the sky
was blue I disagree yoink give me your
money so this resulted in uh PayPal
coming out being like no no it was an
arrows and arrows a mistake so the first
thing I want to say
because it affects us several months ago
we took PayPal off timcast.com and we
knew something like this was coming
we've we've seen too much ESG in banking
institutions too much censorship we knew
it was a huge vulnerability so we signed
up with parallel economy when you go to
timcast.com and become a member the
default option is parallel economy
secondary option is stripe Stripes okay
they're not perfect parallel economy is
very very good they're not perfect but
Dan bongino co-founded this to be more
censorship resistant so many people
chose to remain as members using PayPal
I recommend you guys switch over if you
can I'm not sure there's a seamless way
to do it if you when you signed up many
people signed up as guests with a guest
PayPal account that means you just
terminate your account at timcast.com
and then re-sign up but of course that
means you'll get charged 10 bucks again
so if you're in like the middle of the
month
it's it's kind of it kind of sucks I
guess I would say for for for those
in that situation wait until your month
is over and then before your charge next
cancel and then switch over or something
like that that would be that that would
be good or if you really don't mind a
couple bucks it does support us because
we we do use it to to you know obviously
uh conduct operations here at timcast
but this is bad and I gotta say right
now
1. trial balloon I certainly think so
they they probably would have ran with
this if there wasn't a major backlash to
it and I think uh I think the other
thing is just well I shouldn't say
there's two things regardless of of the
first uh instance the trial balloon this
will eventually become normal mainstream
they are going to implement this they
just did it with a heavy hand so it's
coming yeah I mean uh absolutely and
PayPal has been doing this for a very
long time they have been weaponized for
the benefit of the political state for a
very long time including originally uh
from when I remember going after Julian
Assange freezing his ability to be able
to collect money online they went after
crypto individuals they went after a
free speech Union they partnered with
the splc a discredited horrible
organization that of course was sued
successfully many times for defamation
and slander of individuals that they
attacked politically so PayPal does not
have the best interest I'm switching
mine I already switched mine to an
alternative I'm switching to more
alternatives because the free market is
where it's at and and PayPal has had a
dominance in the space some people have
said that they are a monopoly I kind of
agree with them because a lot of people
uh have been politically shut off from
PayPal and are unable to to do a lot of
banking online because of that larger
Target put on put on their backs
artificially by PayPal if anyone wants
to know Vanguard BlackRock and State
Street own about 18 of PayPal makes
sense as they do with so many
corporations that are what what about
internationally do they have a lot of
international interests that's that's
what I wonder PayPal no a Vanguard
BlackRock and State Street
because I I was talking to a real estate
agent we you know obviously we're
expanding we want to do our brick and
mortar shop and the guy mentioned
something about financing for big
properties with like BlackRock I started
laughing and I was like I don't want to
go anywhere near those companies you
know these these things they they do I
don't maybe it wasn't black or maybe was
it different maybe it was Black Stone
Stones doing the housing developments
right right but then they're like uh but
there were there were similar companies
right they're related in some way yeah
the one was a spin-off of the other yeah
yeah
what I see with this is you know we've
been talking about nuclear war and
everything what I see here is
I don't know if if Civil War is the
right word but some kind of look it's
it's policies like this that if they
were to effectively Implement would
result in some kind of I don't know
Insurgency you're if we keep censoring
people if we keep shutting down
businesses if we if if the the doj is
continually going after only one
political faction eventually you get
some kind of disruption and fighting and
destabilization in the United States so
I guess my question to you is do you
think that there is a potential with the
expansion of these kind of policies into
Civil War or revolutionary kind of
Insurgency and fighting within the
country again we talked about Ray dalio
earlier earlier this year mentioning
that he thinks there's a 30 chance of
civil war after the next presidential
election if it's close especially uh the
losing side may say you know I don't buy
it and especially if they continue to be
so split in policies and philosophies I
mean the US is very much a split kind
country and so you could see I mean I'm
in Texas now in the Texas movement the
Texas leave the United States succeed
movement is is very very big it has a
lot of support I mean some polls show
most Texans support getting out of the
country wow so you could see uh you
could see the country falling apart it
could happen now would it be a shooting
War I have a hard time civil unrest I
can see I don't see you know a civil war
like our Civil War uh I just don't think
the military would get involved in that
I don't think they would fight in
something like that so I don't see that
kind of a civil war but I can certainly
see uh States like Texas and you know I
personally believe that the the
constitution in my reading of it is that
you don't have to you know you're not
forced to stay in forever and that's
just the Supreme Court has tried to make
some decisions since then but the
Supreme Court made it made a decision in
the mid 30s that basically said you know
what screw the Constitution forget about
the 10th Amendment Congress you can pass
whatever ever you want and spending
whatever you want the Supreme Court
basically nullified the Constitution at
least the 10th Amendment in the mid 30s
and then they proceeded to do other
things so yeah there's nothing in the
Constitution that says the state has to
stay in the union forever and Texas
knows it there's there's movements
elsewhere so they could really take off
after a bad uh contested election and if
they go there's no force in the back end
the really odd thing is I could I could
foresee a country like Texas succeeding
and then telling the United States you
know what we're out of your stupid
domestic socialism policies but we'll
stay alive with you we'll continue to
send Texans into the US Military and
we'll be alive with you and if the
Democrats said no to that the next best
thing they could do is Texas could go
you know what let's join the British
Commonwealth
seriously I doubt support the British
Military and we'll go back into the well
the Commonwealth may be less of a bad
fit than being with the Socialist
Democratic controlled United States the
UK not doing too well in that front
they're about 10 times worse than the
Democratic Socialist problems in the
United States correct but in the
Commonwealth they don't have to take
their domestic policies I'm just in
their military I'm talking about for
military and foreign policy not for
domestic policies I don't know maybe it
may be ironic though to have some U.S
states succeed and go back and join the
Commonwealth I don't I don't that one
seems like a long shot but I do see a
possibility of what people refer to as
National divorce or peaceful divorce but
here's the thing about the PayPal stuff
it's it's a big example of of how we're
getting into this dangerous
authoritarian period the fact that a
financial institution would say we can
take money from your business from your
account regardless if you say things we
don't like that's nightmarish at the
same time stripe emerged and now they're
competing heavily with PayPal locals
which is now Rumble uses stripe parallel
economy emerges
it is bad what PayPal is doing they are
powerful they are dominant but maybe
these uh these alternatives are
inevitable you know when Facebook was
engaging in all the censorship at the
height of uh of 2020 or 2018 and 2019
into 2020. a lot of people were saying
don't worry an alternative will emerge
eventually and many have but I also kind
of think just Facebook is kind of just
dwindling as it is with with the younger
people and Tick Tock is getting picked
up which is even worse so I don't think
there's always a solution in that the
market will provide but we are seeing at
least when it comes to PayPal the market
here hit them by six percent users are
jumping ship maybe that's the the white
pill moment that's the optimistic thing
that as much as things are getting bad
this PayPal's backlash I'll say this
looks like a de-escalation in terms of
all the stuff well they reversed the
policy which speaks volumes I mean for
them to come out with a bold policy
saying that they're going to steal
Grandma's purse in the middle of the
night as she's walking down the street
as a pretty egregious move for for the
crime of wrong thing it's absolutely
wild that they could try to justify
stealing and theft like a government
would from its citizens as a form of
punishing people for thinking
incorrectly and and I I think yes it's
optimistic that they reversed it but
it's also pretty crazy that they thought
that they could get they could get away
with this that's that's another part of
this that we need to to understand here
they thought that this was viable they
thought that this was okay which is
absolutely insane and this shows you how
far they go when it comes to mind
control and when it comes to policing
the thoughts of of American citizens to
the point where they're like we're just
going to take it all oh yeah get in my
head for a minute I'm an Austrian Banker
I run the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland I'm letting
the U.S survive with my money if I want
to cut them off from my money supply can
the most annoying thing in the world
right now is American republicanism
because they think that they're so great
they think it's they're the best they're
screwing up they're obese they're
screwing up the country I would love
nothing more than to see the United
States split apart in a civil war
because that's the biggest threat to my
Global takeover I want to spread my seed
I want everyone using my money I want
the bank for international settlements
to be running the world and the
Americans are annoying men so
that's that that's that perspective of
this global banking cartel that's what
stripe is doing ethereum is the
alternate it's not about dollars and
sense great that parallel economies
using American dollars fiat currency
Federal Reserve notes for now great that
Stripes doing it Stripes still private I
think they're looking at going public
which means blackrock's going to own
them pretty soon I don't know when
that's happening or they've been talking
about it since 2021. people are going to
take that clip of you saying you want to
spread your seat everywhere
I want to inseminate the world with my
Fiat crap but if it looks like ethereum
which is also kind of on a path to Fiat
unfortunately with their transition to
proof of stake now instead of proof of
proof of work doesn't matter who's
making the currency that matters who has
it they're going to be making more I
don't think it's fiat currency I mean I
mean I'm I'm an ethereum fan and there
are other great blockchains and
cryptocurrency Bitcoin was you know
applaud for being the first but it's not
a very good one and it wasn't expected
to be just to prove the concept but
there are a lot of great
cryptocurrencies which I mean Zell is
the enhanced as an alternative to PayPal
just doing it with your Zell and your
bank but the long-term uh Evolution
could well be cryptocurrency that is
controlled by no one other than people
using it so the ethereum their new uh
their new uh process to confirm a block
of data and to lock it in you know
you're just it's people like me I'm one
of them now I have some of my ethereum
I've pledged to go to their system so
it's not like a it's not like I'm
pledging US dollars or fiat currency I'm
pledging ether I heard some rumors that
that some people on the ethereum network
were working with like the world
economic forum and their vision of a
centralized currency they are well this
is what I read is that ethereum is going
to be the one world government coin well
it's also important so by ethereum is
what you're saying no no
Bitcoin has 19 million Bitcoins 21
million that'll ever be printed they can
be broken down in what are called
satoshi's which is the lowest decimal
now so we have a finite amount of them
they're not Fiat uh in that sense
there's a finite amount but ethereum can
be printed indefinitely as it's
currently standing which means that you
know if enough inflation happens fast
enough you're just going to see an
escalation and a Fiat explosion of
ethereum too
um they could always evolve it create a
fork create ethereum three that's
actually deflationary by nature which I
think is the future of crypto is a
crypto that as long as it sits there
it's constantly degrading in value you
have one today you're losing point zero
zero one percent of that every day so
you're encouraged to spend it you want
circulation of currency you want
currency circulating through any given
system that's what a currency is it's a
current it's a current and just to add
to your point the BlackRock CEO came out
not so long ago and he said this
Ukrainian War could be used to quote
accelerate the use of Central Bank
digital currencies so these fed coins
these these these coins orchestrated by
the federal reserves and central banks
are already being implemented in places
like Canada and Australia the U.S
federal reserve is talking about
implementing one here in the United
States so a lot of people foresee a
deliberate brought on economic Calamity
that's engineered here in the United
States in order to bring on these
centralized digital currencies which of
course will track trace and database and
also create a social credit score like
system that will track how much carbon
you produce that will of course also
punish you for your wrong political
thoughts this is what PayPal is probably
working on on the back end this is what
the Federal Reserve is already working
on and implementing in many other
countries which should scare the utter
crap out of everyone paying attention
right now I think of the it's it's
inevitable that the writing's been on
the wall since maybe the 1980s really
since the Federal Reserve formed and
realized yo we're just going to inflate
this thing until we can't anymore they
have to have some like Future Vision of
what it's going to become and it doesn't
surprise me that it's a global trackable
current currency that's digital and can
be shut off with the flip of a switch
where did you see that they said
ethereum would be like that Global
Currency if I can find an article about
it who said that it was some article I
was reading uh I don't disagree
um I was even thinking that it'd be it'd
be Bitcoin the issue is Bitcoin you
mentioned it was the you know first in
best dress it's it's so it's not
necessarily the best one but it came in
looking good and it worked but the best
thing about it is that it's truly
decentralized and many of these other
cryptos are centralized in some capacity
there was some controversy with a
particular coin I'm not going to mention
because it's proprietary but people were
shocked to discover that they increased
the volume when they said they couldn't
and they did because when you have
centralized digital currency they can
they can control it
did you find it it didn't pop up I'll
see if I can pull it up tonight though
ethereum makes sense I mean doesn't
doesn't ethereum uh no I don't want to
say things I don't know for sure but
ethereum makes sense because it's it's
seemingly the more institutional of the
cryptocurrencies they're getting a lot
of support Bitcoin Bitcoin of course
does but too many anarchists
Libertarians and radicals support
Bitcoin for me to think that's they're
gonna actually try and use that they
want control they also want infinite
Supply ethereum provides the possibility
for an infinite Supply what will happen
is you'll be like you were saying you're
staking the ethereum which means that
you put some into a node and then that
node generates interest I I think it's
actually this I don't know exactly if
it's written into the code of the
ethereum 2 itself that it auto-generates
interest and so it's set to expand at a
certain rate but what will happen is
we'll each have our own nodes people
will probably start selling you little
boxes you plug into your wall and you
tap into with your phone and your
ethereum is going to be on your wall
which is dangerous because someone can
steal that so then we'll create these
like Bank nodes that are like 10 miles
away in a very secure location there's a
node that you can Port into with your
phone where all your ethereum is stored
collecting you interest and then there
will be maybe there'll be a master node
in Bank of international settlements in
Switzerland who knows where they're
going to put the masternode but
eventually they'll start noting up and
then re-centralize the thing no I don't
think they I think it's a surreal
ethereum is a real blockchain it is
decentralized it'll always stay that way
proprietary
no no it literally is it I mean the
problem with Bitcoin is it takes 10
minutes or maybe more to process a block
so potentially I could buy something
with you paying Bitcoin if the block
doesn't process you know you don't get
paid you may want to win I don't want to
wait 10 minutes for the block to process
Bitcoin is just not feasible for use but
ethereum and as it advances more can do
really fast processing and can be used
for something like a cryptocurrency that
you use everyday life that is not
controlled by a bank it's controlled by
the ethereum blockchain but if a bank
owns 51 of the chain then or if a cabal
of people owns 51 it's not it's not
likely but it is a possibility and I
think we should resolve every
contingency when we're planning a future
of Global Currency like if it can be
done it may very well be done so we
should watch out for people taking
control of the nodes
you can track everybody you know with
with Bitcoin uh I believe the ethereum
chain it's all publicly available as
well right all the transactions yeah on
um ether scan I went to I better
self-offs when we talk about uh crypto I
went to Davos several years ago and
crypto was the theme I wasn't in the
actual World economic Forum in the city
of Davos that every all everybody shows
up and then tries to suck all the teat
of the world economic Forum outside of
it to be like look at me look at me I
want to be part of your thing but
there's pop-ups everywhere bars clubs
partying and people do their mini events
in the periphery and crypto was it
everyone was like this is the future
this is what we're doing since then I've
been telling people like yo the world
economic Forum types they love crypto
they want that I mean think about what
Bitcoin is it's a arguably a Global
Currency it comes out they get all the
the right wing nut jobs to start using
it and cheering for it they all become
rich overnight this sings the Praises of
it and all of a sudden they're like this
is our way out of the machine and the
Machine is just like oh we love that
everyone's adopting this universe
reversal digital currency that can track
every move you make another reason why
the world economic forum and the global
monetary system doesn't like Bitcoin but
they prefer ethereum is because
bitcoin's energy intensive the mining
process requires that you have a GPU
plugged into a wall it's burning a lot
of coal or whatever your power it
whereas the proof of stake stuff it's
just the digital code on some node
somewhere is just repopulating and
adding new
um gain you know it doesn't require any
mining electricity it's just like in
this program in the in the net the
problem is that the power goes out then
none of it's worth anything right I was
going to ask if the power goes out what
are we going to do yeah when I ask that
question to a group of developers it's
stunned silence
you put the blockchain on on you know
the smoke signal and that's how you
transfer I promise that's how much I had
you send the private key and then you
send the public key and then boom yeah
and everyone can see your private key
there it is
I didn't cash you got to maintain cash
well we have dealt with that problem at
fortitude Ranch because we do have a
cryptocurrency it's called the fortitude
this is a fake one not the real one it
runs it's an erc20 token runs on the
ethereum blockchain you can use our
tokens to buy membership uh but what
happens if you know the grid goes down
there's no ethereum blockchain you can't
use them so if you want you can say Hey
you know I'm the one who bought this uh
these fortitude tokens I'll put it on my
spreadsheet on my computer I keep
offline and if the Grid's down but you
can still contact me I know that you
know you know you own you know you own
15 fortitudes and you are entitled to
join fortuitude Ranch in because when
the [ __ ] hits the fan for for fortitude
Ranch and every everyone wants to join
we've got a page ready to come up on our
website it says we're no longer
accepting cash memberships you can only
join with fortitude tokens because
people have bought them in the past part
of the allures if you own fortitudes
you're not a member of 14 Ranch but you
we will give you priority to join Over
cash buyers is it I've been selling them
for that is there any kind of like thing
on there where I can scan it and it'll
bring up my fortitude not on this this
is completely a trinket you know for
show but uh you know it's it's a normal
erc20 token so you can see it on the
blockchain if you if you search for
fortitudes frt is our symbol we're hard
to find we're trading frt yeah that's
unfortunate yeah sorry
I'm gonna go coinmarketcap.com and look
up the frt but we're not widely traded
at all
fertilizer your company owns most of the
tokens we have people who bought them
one to join and then some of bottomless
Investments you couldn't get FRC
fortitude Ranch currency or Nah
fortitude is the name we used 42 minutes
all right everybody I'll give this one
here to you oh yeah in Forts blockchain
and individual Freedom We Trust oh cool
slide it over
that's very cool
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button we're
gonna go to super chats now so uh smash
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show up at 11 p.m but we're
gonna read now your super chats
we got Hunter he says b corporations
part of the stakeholder economy help
make sure that your money is going to
the local economy and fight shareholder
Primacy it also ties the mission
statements to the corporation even with
other owners investment
yeah interesting you could like that's
what I was talking about like nodes like
10 miles away where like 10 000 people
are hosting their money then you could
withdraw taxes from the node to finance
surrounding projects and stuff localized
taxing and things like that interesting
Helicon drummer says switch timcast
account from PayPal today my
understanding is Their fines could also
be used against anyone purchasing
Firearms or related items I don't did
you see did you see that I think I saw
something like that yeah you can't use
PayPal to buy uh anything related to
Firearms already so they already have an
anti-fire on policy
yeah and PayPal yeah but this is why it
was like a year ago we were like we need
to find a way to get rid of PayPal
PayPal doesn't want you defending
yourself as they steal money from you
sorry maybe that's why they banned
firearm purchases sorry I have to say
that
Cantara Bella says wild switching to
parallel Rumble use your voice dollars
that's right
um so we put everything up on Rumble and
I'm really you know look it's really
cool we've got I think Tim castillarella
is like 300 000 subscribers on Rumble
and uh my Tim cast channel has like 300
300 000 I think as well my Tim pool
Channel doesn't so we just we're moving
that segment over to the Tim cast one
more than most of the subscribers are
but it's cool to see that there's
actually some rivaling happening to
YouTube the fact that I've got hundreds
of thousands of Subs on these platforms
makes it a viable platform to keep using
IF YouTube wants to play dirty games the
market shall provide and so so it seems
not a guarantee it's not the best but
you know
but that being said that's why we use
parallel economy shout out Dan bongino
who I think is doing more than most when
it comes to actually building a parallel
economy and pushing back on the
censorship because Rumble and uh
parallel economy are huge I think here's
what we need we got a brick and mortar
location coming soon for something it's
going to be a hangout venue Club games
I'm hoping the parallel economy can
actually set up pay terminals so that we
can use them for our general Payment
Processing as well because we need
stores to start doing that stuff then
you can't get silence censored or shut
down for what your business is
and if you use the Public Square app
which will show you a list of businesses
that support American values all of
those businesses should also be using
parallel economy oh I just got this in
PayPal this is from was this Bloomberg
PayPal has no intention to find
customers over misinformation yeah they
walk back to the policy oh yeah now
they're just saying they never intended
it to begin with so it was an area it's
official yes well so I got to say this
then uh the loss of money I've incurred
from people canceling their accounts
is uh is Paypal gonna pay damages for
that they admitted it was an error this
wasn't a policy change they can claim
they're allowed to make this was them
publishing false information which
caused a stop pain and suffering damages
to all of these businesses yeah got them
so maybe I don't know I mean what do
they lose five percent six six percent
of their value in one day it's a lot we
we lost a lot of members
so here's what happens there are people
who've signed up to simpcast.com using
PayPal
these are people who are probably not
super fans of the show but they're fans
enough to be like yeah you know I'll
sign up I'll support the guy yeah here
you go
but they don't watch every episode they
don't really pay attention that much
when they cancel their account they
don't come back to the website and
re-sign up those are customers that we
have to try and email and ask me like
hey did you still want to be a member so
when we lose that money because PayPal
published a false statement I think
they're responsible and they should have
to pay the damages to every single
business because of that error you don't
get to like you know if you're a
repairman and you're coming to fix my
window and then you you break it you got
to pay for it I'm not paying for that
PayPal busted up the system and now it's
costing custom that's their fault it's
like a venue if you're putting on a show
in the one day the venue's like and
we're not letting anyone in that isn't
six seven or has green hair or it
doesn't didn't get their vaccine then
you as like a performer that has tickets
bought and then you lose all this money
on your tickets all these refunds you
can probably go after the venue for that
that's a way better analogy you you book
a show at a venue people are buying
tickets and the venue comes out and
announces they're taking everyone's
tickets away at their own discretion so
people rip their tickets up and leave
and demand refunds and now I'm left with
no money because the venue comes out and
said no no that was a real statement
that was fake and I'm like okay well now
that my Show's ruined and my business
has been destroyed because of what you
just did you got to pay yeah at least
what class action is that the way you
would go all the people harmed by class
action I think is always a bad idea the
only person who wins a class action is
the lawyer yep all right president Arena
Vladimir Vladimir avna says one of the
things related to the world economic
Forum you will owe nothing shtick that I
don't see many people talking about is
the insane amount of subscription-based
services like Spotify I recently bought
a custom Zune so all of my music has
kept offline and safe good idea because
uh people are buying their way into
communism
everything is becoming subscription I go
on Amazon and uh I'm like I need I need
a coconut water and it's like a default
subscribe yeah the default is not to buy
a case it's to subscribe to coconut
water I'm not subscribing to that when
we run out I'll buy more I guess we
should subscribe I don't know we have a
subscription to toilet paper
we do it's a bamboo toilet paper though
and so once a month we get a thing like
we have we have 30 employees we have
this you know 12 000 square foot
facility so we gotta you know we gotta
keep the bathroom stocked up so we
bought a subscription everything's gonna
be that says automated subscription
processing and then in 20 years when
Amazon owns every single business you
will have a subscription to Amazon for
your services and you won't realize it
but you will have bought your way into
account the tactic is like we'll give
you 10 off if you subscribe for a
monthly purchase and then when you
forget that you're subscribed that one
extra month it pays off the 10 game that
you had and they're just hoping people
forget and that's the danger for
businesses is it's good to have an
accountant going through all the order
lists every time every month so that
you're not accidentally ordering things
you don't need
right all right Cabo Rojo says Tim and
Co you inspired us to go all in on
fighting the culture War through music
just released the Reckoning by single
grain of sand definitely see the value
is speaking truth via music only on
Rumble half of the GP goes to 1.6 uh one
six prisoners cool glad to hear it
Troy Dunham had a huge debate this
weekend with family over Biden's
invention of the term next nail recent I
couldn't find video evidence anywhere
please confirm and provide any sources
or context they were also dubious of
badakav care but I did find that one
there was a video I saw it may have been
Nuance bro I'm not sure where uh I don't
remember who it was they went over the
The Joe Biden's new language and they
showed all the clips next nail recent
battle kef care but I mean just show
them trunan on a shot but of pressure
come on show them all right I'll start
with two words made in America
and then be like come on it's three
words Lauren bobert tweeted out I have
two words let's go Brandon and
everyone's like she's such an idiot she
said two words and she said three what
an idiot but they didn't know that Biden
did that I guess and that's the point
yeah no but what she did uh whether I'm
on purpose or not perfectly exposed the
cult these people don't even listen to
the president they voted for speaking
Yeah we as people I don't know who you
voted for but we're people who are no
fans of Joe Biden I'm assuming you surge
too and but we watch his speeches and so
when he says it we all watch it happen
when he says to pressure we're all
talking about it like did you see what
just happened all of these people like
George Takei David Hogg these other guys
they don't even watch him and they voted
for him and then when we come out and
we're like look how crazy he is they go
huh you're so dumb it's like did what
how are you supposed to negotiate with a
group of people that are like that when
they're just like I don't know I don't
care I won't watch him and you're dumb
what do you do like you were in the
military I don't know if you worked with
conflict resolution much but like if
you're up against like the Taliban how
do you end up negotiating you just take
one of their leaders and you give them a
lucrative bribe to negotiate with the
entire group um military doesn't really
get into the negotiation it's supposed
to be the state department handling that
so
yeah the the US military doesn't
de-escalate all right let's read more we
got MIT for Mo too
says happy Columbus Day
happy Columbus day indeed today's the
day we celebrate when a bunch of
Europeans figured out there was another
part of the planet dude uh this who was
it the oh uh Spike Cohen tweeted out the
history of Columbus Day it was like in
the late 1800s a bunch there's this
abusive lynching of a bunch of Irish
Americans so then William Henry Harrison
was like you know what no no we'll make
a day after the Italian Adventure
Christopher Columbus yay now it's not so
bad what they did to you Italians and
then it was in like the 1930s that uh
there was all this anti-italian American
sentiment because of the war and you
know Mussolini's Italy so they were just
persecuted again and then it was FDR was
like we're officially making Columbus
Day a holiday to appease you all right
let's read this one
one two says what information do you
have Putin is losing my info says
otherwise plus he took 20 of the country
why would Saudi Arabia get in this get
on the side with Russia if they were
losing
money well for Saudi Arabia it was I
think less Russia than Iran that um you
know the US has not been holding Iran
back from their nuclear weapons program
and there's a lot of concern that you
know Saudis are worried about that but
they want oil prices to go up and
Russia's helping them on that so they're
playing their economic interests and
Iran is an ally of Russia and you know
they're doing what they got to do to
protect their own self-interest
all right well I'll just add to that
you got to choose who you trust I mean I
think it's fair to say that Putin is
losing simply because he's fighting NATO
he's fighting all of NATO uh we're
supplying weapons intelligence we've got
volunteer Ground Forces but now we have
confirmed Special Operations on the
ground Germany's providing air defense
Biden's going to be sending air defense
so when the news reports come out and
they're like Putin's forces are routed
and retreating I'm like you know he's
fighting like a military Alliance so
it's reasonable to me to assume granted
I do think it's all propaganda and I
think Russia is probably doing better in
certain areas than you'd ever find out
because they're not going to come out
and be like yes all of our troops are
losing now let's go and fight more they
need to justify why the money needs to
be sent there and so Putin has to be
doing well enough that they need the
money but not so well it's a lost cause
do you have any other kind of
intelligence or assessments to why
Russia is is losing well their troops
aren't fighting well they're just not
motivated compared to the ukrainians I
mean it's why did the Russians fight so
well in World War II Germany was
invading their territory and killing
them off they're now invading uh Ukraine
and they're not doing well and they've
not been doing well they've been
suffering High casualties they are
definitely losing the war losing
territory and the mobilization going on
is not being well received in the
country and uh just they're not
mobilizing I was as a reservist and an
air guard from person when you mobilize
us we're ready to go the troops they're
trying to mobilize are conscripts they
got to train them they got to equip them
it's going to be a long time for them to
build that Force up and it's not a ready
to go force and they're going to
continue to go badly which is why the
risk of them escalating the nuclear
weapons use are some other retaliation
against us like a bio attack is very
real now all right insert name here says
YouTube is giving zero TP notifications
now I have to deliberately search for
you also Shameless plug for my friend
who released a poetry book our little
black book by Ren ivy for some
distraction and almost Last Jedi says
YouTube have reached a new low as well
as not getting notifications I got
unsubscribed today wonder why I couldn't
find the live stream and uh today was
one of those days where Ian reminded me
at the last minute the thumbnail doesn't
go up when we launch the live stream the
thumbnail is a gray block and I have to
immediately then re-upload the thumbnail
otherwise people scroll rolling through
don't see it and don't and they wonder
why it is they're not seeing it's
because YouTube is playing dirty games
so be the notification you want to see
the see in the world every Monday
through Friday
8 P.M we are live at youtube.com
timcastirl live you can just take that
and you can post it and share whatever
or use the the actual direct URL at the
top of the video and uh share it you can
also listen on iTunes and Spotify and
all the other podcast platforms too
because we do post it there at night as
well
let's read some more Super chats let's
let's see what you got guys
all right let's see
we'll grab a good one I'm trying to find
a good good question
AJ Cook says your guest is a nice guy
I'm sure but his opinions on Russia are
cringe CIA MI6 propaganda ask Russians
with Attitude to recommend a guest who
can comment intelligently on their side
of the story like armchair Warlord
oh yeah I would just say uh it's who you
trust it sounds like you trust the
government you trust the United States
and the media reporting here uh no I
trust them in terms of biological
weapons program so I don't think we're
developing biological weapons Romania
let me put it in a way that people who
don't trust government might understand
better like for example the preparedness
Community a lot of people say oh FEMA is
going to do concentration camps against
Americans and that's been out there a
lot and it's absolute nonsense you know
the people who work for VMware are
largely good people and if there was
some massive conspiracy of FEMA
concentration camps if there was some
program with the U.S has secretly
developing biological weapons a lot of
people would have to be involved in
doing that and the secret would
eventually get out if we had a
biological weapons program you would
know about it it would be leaked we just
you know you don't have a lot of faith
in the confidence of people in
government then why would you think that
they can carry out some vast conspiracy
some brilliant conspiracy and keep it
secret they're not that capable
so whether you trust them are not the
truth is you know there is no FEMA
concentration camp conspiracy like some
people think well right there is no
biological weapons program that the
United States if there was it would leak
but when it comes to the war with uh the
war in in Ukraine why assume that the
reporting coming out is good if we if we
if we think the US government isn't
capable of these kind of organizational
Feats then why would I assume that
there's any effective intelligence or
armaments happening as or honest
reporting as it pertains to Ukraine I
mean I'll put it this way there's no way
Ukraine wins this war if NATO wasn't
backing him they would have been
steamrolled in two seconds the US is
clearly involved so why should I believe
you're involved in the war we are
supporting Ukraine there's there's no
doubt no yeah right so why should I
assume that the U.S doesn't have the
capabilities of this level of
organization when arguably if they're
winning in Ukraine they're actively
doing it
I'm sorry I don't follow that if if the
argument is that the U.S can't operate
the government doesn't have the
capability to operate say camps that
they would use to to bring people to in
the event of some kind of Chrysler
catastrophe then I mean you're assuming
the government is incapable of doing
this there is no FEMA plan in a kind of
collapse situation to round up Americans
and put them in concentration camps
there is no plan that you know we're
going to invite in United Nations troops
to take over the country I don't know
sure so if you're a nonsense like this
all the time and you know even if it's
legitimate if even if you believe it
might be true you probably don't trust
government officials so you shouldn't
trust that there is a capability for
them to want organize something like
this and then two to carry it out and to
keep it secret so don't worry about
ridiculous sounding government
conspiracy theories they're not true
they're probably not true probably not I
just had a conniption
I respectfully absolutely 100 disagree
they lied about the Vietnam War the Gulf
War 1 Gulf War II Libya Syria
Afghanistan they lied about so much why
would they not be lying now and I think
it's best to be skeptical of government
and to quote and and to just quote
Ronald Reagan here I think the most
terrifying words on the planet are I'm
from the government and I'm here to help
no I'm I'm not a you know I've been
criticizing government throughout your
program you know the avian flu research
that was not so much that it was done
the fact that they published it that's
what bothered me the most about it was
publishing the how do you make avian flu
mammal to mammal ferrets in their
research but human human uh transmission
so I'm not a huge fan of government but
the conspiracy theories of hey were got
FEMA concentration camps are in the war
or United Nation troops are going to be
invited in to take over the country or
that we're developing biological weapons
it's not was it was it a conspiracy was
it a conspiracy on the United States in
turn to Japanese people in camps no they
absolutely but that happened before so
so so why would you say it's impossible
to happen when it happened before I'm
saying there is no FEMA Pro program to
set up concentration camps against
Americans or to bring in United Nations
troops I run into people who believe
that and it it's just nonsense what you
ought to believe in is real threats like
Russia using nuclear weapons like a
biological agent like human human
transmission
without invent inventing false
government conspiracies so you you but
you're doing two things I disagree with
the first is uh bringing the UN into it
is sort of like a straw man like
obviously that's your that's fairly
often for sure for sure but I mean
there's posters you can find in Nebraska
and Texas about you know U.N well let's
let's steal man it Luke is right the U.S
has interned people before they have the
capability to do so they have the
facilities to do so well at 1.5 million
Americans locked up right now as I mean
so the issue is if they created by so
you've done you've done two you're doing
the two things I disagree with one is
incorporating the U.N into it but the
other
is now I'm I'm losing my train of
thought on this one I've lost it Luke
what's going on you you can't just
believe the government blindly because
I I got it I got it I got it back the
the idea that they have a plan for it is
is another mistake they have the
capability to do it they have the
facilities to do it if something bad
happened they've George W bush already
signed a National Security Presidential
Directive 51 meaning they have the
intention to do it if they if they so
want it so it's all there I mean you can
say the un thing is a conspiracy and
I'll just say yeah I don't know anything
about that that seems ridiculous why
would the U.N troops come in here they
don't need it but to say that the US
doesn't have a plan for it perhaps but
they've expressed intent if needed be
the facilities and the individuals if
they need be the conspiracy is always
the intent I don't know that intent
exists I know the capability does so the
president's changed quite a few times
since George Bush so you're saying that
somehow during all these presidential
changes of people you know absolutely
hate each other but yet they manage to
keep this conspiracy or this no no no no
National Security Presidential Directive
51 is an executive order that does exist
and was updated by Barack Obama and so
that's exactly what in the event of a
catastrophic loss of life or damage to
the U.S that could that as a result of
an incident that occurs anywhere on the
planet the president has the authority
to essentially introduce a new
government to supersede the current one
a new constitutional government and and
create a continuity coordinate a
continuity a national continuity
coordinator who would oversee the new
mono government that exists well they
don't know that they do have continuity
right right now the point is
the this executive order exists the
president in this was in 2007 I believe
asserted the authority to over basically
overwrite existing law due to a major
emergency and the need for continuity of
government it's been challenged because
people say it's it's well it's never
been challenged the challenge to it is
that it's never actually faced Supreme
Court scrutiny so they don't they don't
think it would fly however in the event
of a catastrophic event affecting the
government who's going to bring it to
the Supreme Court the point is
Barack Obama updated it it is a
component of the federal of the federal
government and the executive branch
although many people do challenge its
Authority there are uh made in
tournament facilities I mean you you've
got prisons you've got them all over the
place and you've got other uh large open
you know I don't know what these before
but like uh storage facilities
warehouses Etc and the US government has
interned people before I'm not saying
there's a conspiracy to do it I'm not
saying there's a plan to do it my issue
is there doesn't need to be there is the
intention for the government to wipe out
people's laws and you know Wipe Out the
laws enforce a new law at their own
discretion to remove undesirables
there's the capability to do it and
there are the facilities to do it so if
people are concerned it may happen look
if somebody you know is is stacking up
dynamite in front of a building and they
say don't worry we have no intention of
blowing it up and they're lining the
building with it and they're like I've
got a real concern you might do that
they can be like nobody here wants to do
that there's no plan to do that we have
done it before but we're not doing it
now don't be surprised when people freak
out and think you're going to do it yeah
I mean have you ever heard of the
Tuskegee experiments when the US
government heat of knowingly hurt people
they were doing scientific biological
experiments on unsuspecting human beings
the CIA did that with MK Ultra they hurt
and punished and poisoned people the US
government even even spread even spread
radioactive waste inside of the United
States there's there's historical
documented cases of the government doing
large biological testing especially even
with radiation on unsuspecting American
public so why would you ever believe
that that is not ever possible ever
again that's not what I said I didn't
say it's not ever possible again I said
an answer to your question no the U.S
does not have biological weapons
programs now and I don't believe we do
have biological weapons programs now if
we did
it would be illegal and it would
probably be leaked because you wouldn't
be able to keep it secret so I'm not
worried about illegal the government
never does anything illegal so all right
so let me let me ask like so the the the
the the biological research facilities
in Ukraine that the U.S is desperate to
defend
they're doing gain of function research
there they were they admitted that yes
so they're making viruses more dangerous
maybe I don't know the specs of what
they were doing there but that's what
kind of function means yeah you can make
them more dangerous because you got to
develop defenses to them can those can
can the pathogens they were
experimenting on be used as Weapons yes
they could so it's semantics to argue
there's no biological weapons program
and optimistic thinking the United
States could use nuclear weapons to
destroy their own states and cities yeah
theoretically you could it's not really
no no that's not I'm saying that the it
would be like the US is building nuclear
bombs and saying but they're not weapons
they're for Mining and it's like okay
well like can the bomb be dropped on a
city sure
but it's not a weapon it's like look you
can make a padlock into a weapon so it's
it's semantic argument I'll I'll
absolutely concede officially on paper
there's no biological weapons you know
being made but if they're making viruses
more dangerous those can easily be
weaponized and it's just a semantic
argument yeah and have you ever heard of
Agent Orange very much so I wrote the
official Air Force history of the
disposal well that should tell you that
the government is capable of poisoning
poisoning and using bio weapons on large
populations of people let's read a
couple more Super chats and we got Lone
Wolf 36s he says ethereum 2.0 just came
out it's already controlled it's now
impossible to mine it oh wow yeah it's
not controlled it's a new proof of stake
method they're not doing the mining and
where they just changed it yeah you can
still mine ethereum one
Pioneer smoke House's Channel says AWS
controls the nodes now they moved
electric use from miners to AWS and they
can stop at any time very concerning I
read that and I didn't know if it was
true or not is that they're using AWS I
don't know who to confirm it with it's
so new I don't know but uh I wouldn't be
surprised if that's true bro it's going
to be Amazon centralization of the
ownership of the direction of your money
man Jeff Bezos he's going to sell you
everything you need they're already
doing it they're going to Amazon what
does it Amazon discount if your
ethereum's already in the Amazon account
you'll get a discount on Amazon products
host on our node yeah Amazon literally
has stores at a new store opened up in
North Hollywood it literally really is
that is that is it is that the one where
like you can walk in without a clerk or
whatever a cashier I don't know for sure
I didn't really go in there it wasn't
really my I'm not the target audience
you know but uh I assume so I assume if
it's Amazon they were talking about it
yeah I went to that one in uh Seattle
and uh we did a little stunt where we
proved it's really easy to just take
whatever you want without paying for it
and uh
it was really simple
um I don't know if I can actually say
exactly what we did I might have already
said it but I said because I didn't want
people to go do it it's it's really
really simple to do but I was able to
walk out and only pay for one thing out
of like 10. and uh I should say in my
account we did pay for everything we
didn't steal anything we just yeah we
just figured out a loophole and then
made sure everything was paid up but we
proved that you didn't you didn't you
could easily do this I called the
company and when I explained what I did
they went oh we don't care
and I the gist of it was that the um
the amount of money they save by not
having employees covers any potential
loss from glitches in the system right
that'll be your future there will be
just buildings you walk in and grab
stuff and then it just deducts the
crypto from your account and if it's an
error nobody cares congratulations you
know you jaywalk you get fined money
gets automatically taken out of your
account that's right commit wrong think
your child can't go to school anymore
you say a naughty word PayPal takes a
bunch of money from your financial
account you can't get a plane ticket or
train ticket anymore your internet
service is cut down right already
happening in China right exactly
all right my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button and subscribe to this channel
apparently some people have been
unsubscribed and become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you at about 11
p.m you don't want to miss it we've got
a lot of a lot more fun stuff to talk
about a lot of creepy stuff to talk
about because you know how it gets it
gets a little spicy on the members only
show so again smash the like button you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me at timcast Drew do you
want to shout anything out I know just
if you're interested in 14 Ranch uh
working for us franchising or joining
it's
www.4tubekranch.com
absolutely thanks for coming man I still
have a gazillion things I want to talk
about and I usually talk about them on
Luke uncensored.com we're also of course
implementing alternatives to PayPal we
got another second alternative that
we're going to be implementing very soon
today I made a video where I was
screaming on the top of my lungs I
couldn't control myself I couldn't hold
it back to watch that video check it out
on Luke uncensored.com thank you so much
for having me great discussion thank you
for the their opinions yeah big time man
thanks thanks for clarifying the
depleted uranium isn't considered
tactical nuclear weaponry uh also keep
in mind deflationary currency is the
future of a sustainable currency where
the longer it sits there the more it
dissipates so you want to keep it moving
uh then we can make more of it when new
people are born so it encourages growth
of humans
um of course it's not just about the
number of humans it's about the value of
the human Story You're calculating human
body heat to see how much cryptos
produced let's find out and let's do it
together I love you see you later
all right and you guys can follow me on
Instagram at surge.com spelled out I
don't have anything on Twitter or
anything I might if Elon goes through
with the buy we'll see but uh as of now
that's everything thank you let's make a
crypto where as soon as you're born you
get like a hundred tokens and then like
everybody gets 100 tokens and then when
you're born you get one and then you can
trade and stuff with it but like there
you go you're alive here's some money
yeah it might be something like that
like every for every like Jewel of heat
your body produces you get a crypto
token added to your account or something
but you got to be in the Pod and eating
the bugs all right everybody we'll see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out see ya